et la partie qui n'a pas encore commencé
on voit les deux joueurs face à face
on va mettre les l'échiquier dsk main
bah oui je veux juste vérifier que la
bascule et bien marché oui basculant
bousculade on a été basculée aide yoyo
la fine fleur de feu gadr
temps va on va on va tout de suite voir
on va tout de suite le savoir
eh bien il est parti pour kto sinko
donné pour
petrov marocaine vérifie
si
tu sais on est là sont les banques a
bâti de petrov il va sans les voir 4 tu
à partir et donc karl scène fidèle à
ce qui nous fait dans les matchs
maintenant il va paix à la pêche à
droite à gauche alors qu'il aurait pu
essayer d'enfoncer le des cuatro
et donc petit petrov
5e plusieurs fois qu'il faisait
alors un petit combi stafford est bien
en d6 beaucoup mieux joué bravo et
pourtant avec rose elle sur place on
aurait pu penser carrick rosen et
seconde en de yann nepomniachi qu'ils
allaient envoyer le stafford mais pas du
tout mais pas du tout
mais pas du tout donc sa part dans la
vente
principal des quatrains plutôt qpc trois
comptes à vue assez souvent bonjour les
noirs font des cinq ici
l'asymétrie au centre
est-ce que c'est obligatoire ou pas je
pense tu veux faire fawcett mais c'est
probablement inférieure des cinq
il fallait rire est ce que tu penses que
carlson s'attendent à une petrov
ou pas bah moi même tu vois j'ai dit
avant mais qui fasse mon coeur
dis moi je peux mieux attendre j'espère
que
détrompe-toi fabien alors on va voir si
je vous fous des six il vous faut 7 si
je vous fais cinq jeux c'est payet
plusieurs shows jr qui a souvent joué là
petrov n'est pas non plus avec une
grille tchouk finale du grand prix
moscou et j'en étais sûr oui ça fait un
mois qu'il faisait et il a fait qu'on de
manga aux candidats
entre untel mais
non c'est pas ça s'est passé son arme
principale spécialement que et ils
barrent déjà
web alors les blancs normalement ils
font ces quatre ici on peut faire
glisser trois et peut faire qu'il y ait
de me faire tour un bon
mais c'est 4 de loin de loin de loin le
coup le plus jouer ce fait quand une
belle mais peut-être choquer ses 3,5 à
michael bay c ils ont parmi les bons
fauteuil
la faute des arbitres hi hi hi hi hi
bred habitude il changé et du coup c'est
qu'un scène car le faut savoir très
important désolé et puis par l'ouverture
non pas quand même parler de sa g non
c'est quand il laisse de côté une baisse
de partout
phosagro complètement désintégrée
peut-être chutes d'eau des chutes des
bourses mondiales ils ont dû très cher
pour cela ils n'ont plus de quoi payer
le fauteuil et du coup quand une baise
la remplace
a joué ses 4,8 gt coupe et à utiliser
qui avait laissé trois étaient aussi
absents
non mais c'est qu'a très bien donc en
germe les noirs français si ce n'est pas
beaucoup de parties dans kramnik l'écho
là dedans
il était plutôt le fond à cette
chronique
avec ses fils qui avaient quatre tentes
là
mais l'avancé 6 mais moi j'y joue et ça
c'est bon tacle est mort un petit peu et
longtemps 2006 mais tu vois c'est
intéressant
mais libre une nouvelle fois la lie
s'est pas levé pour aller se reposer ils
évoluent est vraiment levé pour le
stress parce que ça par contre c'est un
truc il faut dire moi c'est un truc que
j'ai en partie souvent après le début de
la partie j'ai très envie de et puis ça
veut faire la vidange joueurs et de
revenir à je pense que c'est ça mais ça
traduit du stress oui alors
là il n'a pas pu partir en salle de
repos vous se reposer c'est pas possible
on a reposé du tout c'est la reposer
toute fière d'un mais bon c'est sûr
qu'il va faire et bon hockey soit cahier
ces trois
cas les prends puis on prend et mais en
fait ça ressemble à la junte avait dû
voir la partie france turquie aux
championnats d'europe au stade partie de
jules avec les noirs
on ne sait pas quel turc sabah ne suis
pas lequel c'était soit il ya cd cd key
c3 et pas eu la partie des six pianos
cas contre jules à possible un mais je
veux dire tu peux faire c'est d'essayer
keith et troy et clément
tu peux aussi
considérer tourer ou dams et 2
d'échangés ait marqué ses trois ont
laissé le quai henri iv est attaqué en
général tu gardes fait passer des cds
quoi
comme ça y'a pas de crise et 6
ok mais souvent des noms même photo de
l'option
un
peu mieux pour les blancs ça quand même
genre un peu plus agréables mais tu veux
dire que c'est rien je suis pas au
courant qu'un programme et julie là tout
le temps égalisé enlever ces sages plus
grand qu'un problème en fait
je sais pas quelle ligne maglev à jouer
jules à chaque fois qu'il a joué cette
variante il était bien
auquel on va bien voir un ce sont ces
toutes les options possibles
je vous nous expliquer les avantages des
inconvénients de la petrov à ce stade
bob gainey fins et symétriques quoi
c'est un peu comme une variante des
changes la française oui si tu veux
comparer dans l'esprit entoure un
f5
je pense que même musicale d'être
jouable mais j'ai deux vieux souvenirs
avec même çà çà çà
et estime qu il faut prendre trois
à ce que certains prends ta damages qui
adore prendre quatre
mais bon ça va un peu moins confiance
enfin je veux dire je ne sais pas s'il
fait ça c'est juste qu'il a totalisé
évidemment mais
c'est juste normal quoi on voit toute la
question c'est ce que veulent dire les
blancs c'est qu'ils ont attiré ton
canadien le 4 août pour montrer en fait
à ce niveau là de la partie
à tiens regarde faire un truc marrant
c'est un tour de magie regardez bien
cette position
tu la regardes bien ouais c'est bon tu
l'as mémorisées alors regarde tours de
magie
tu peux en faire face à de très riches
ont fait
trop blanc je fais ouais astro blanc
au noir la même chose incroyable voilà
il ya très peu de jours montre capable
de réaliser son
nom mais en gros ouais ce qui a valu au
centre dans le cadre des noirs et le 5d
blanc c'est juste dire que
il est fragile en fait c'est sa bonne
case doute envie de le mettre mais
justement comment il voit dans la partie
continue ses 4 et ensuite la ffu des
trois tours et tout ça y est
il tombé sur ce qu'ils veulent puisque
du coup ça vient a expliqué après sa non
en vrai je faisais vraiment faisable
pour expliquer aux gens que les noirs et
les blancs il joue sur ce cavalier au
caa tant que ce qu'avait lieu 4 un peu
fragile et peut-être mal classés c'est
pour expliquer ces c'était bon mais
après si jamais les blancs veulent peut
le voir ici tu peux commencer par des
trolls des 4 tu l'envoies f6 tu fais des
4 après mes joueurs c'est pour expliquer
l'idée d'avoir fait des cas directement
et jouer ça mais normalement ça c'est
juste normal jeu comme ça après la
petrov eu des évolutions etc mais
dans les années 80 les blancs les tout
le temps là dedans quoi cherchez pas
trop à comprendre des 90 sociétés
cinq
noms et vomir là
y'a rien autour fab
ça donne la case 5 s'affaiblit toutes
les cases blanches c'est une horreur sow
vandam des droits on veut pas voir ça
tu vas tu as pella
ribes
il faut être 51.5 we love songs of
prey françois dahm ces deux hommes b3 je
ne sais pas
entre autres choses heures mais
on va voir ne me dites pas que dépôt
alors fait pas après tour non non non
non non ils essayent de se rappeler on
va le voir ainsi je mets une cam sur les
voies la voie vraiment là qu'il essaye
de se rappeler 9,5 très bien on a vu
qu'il
la turquie tours 8 existe aussi mais
bien moins joué fou g4 je crois c'est
beau fils il faut 5 clairement mind dam
des trois dames 17 super chaud comme b3
bon après des fois tu sais pas parce que
je réfléchisse sur un coup au début que
tapas qui après un ânon mais il l'a
enfin
et magnus qui fait kiffer béton la
sauver et l'enlève et le matador tirade
qui se voit beaucoup mieux
ah non il cache aucune buzz or
puisque c'est pas interdit de cacher le
corps une baisse comme ça mais n'est pas
la gâcher aussi un mais quand une belle
aisance huard face à ces
règles et il doit être tellement dès qu
on va crever alors je te veux
même b3 ok bon c'est le coup mais enfin
plus ou moins mike
bray couteau théorique sais même pas
s'il y aura une grosse partie en soit il
se rappelle ce rappel pour le reste
nicolas bay seront découpées chauffe on
cotise mathieu dame 17 très bien c'était
joué par eric à six parcs les doigts par
caruana dès 2010 est déjà un régal site
où travaillent maintenant et casinca 9
voilà c'est ce que pendant par la guerre
est juste pour dire qu'ils rient à 6
pour le coup c'est le coup le plus
jouissif la mode a tabassé
et a6
füle principales
lignes époque
l'idée c'est que si tu fais de me
prendre et ça tu te prends québec à
trois
attaques le flou la dalle pourra plus
sortir et genre tu fais d'un merci et je
sais pas quoi et touareg v8 bon au pire
sa reddition mais catastrophe donc
six étaient jouables une époque je sais
pas écoutons donc j'ai pas trop dire
mais faire confiance à matthieu s'il a
dit l'abbé trois dames 17 c'est qu'il a
toujours su mathieu n'est que jeudi
caruana je vais déjà trois parties de
lui en 2017 et caruana bon c'était le
gros joueur de de petrov récent quoi je
serais pas pour que l'arrêté
il car bien que ça petrov après parfois
je me sens que tu dois changer
d'ouverture pour être renouvelée voir
autre chose tu vois il pouvoir sortir
quoi il fallait mais juste non il fait
bon après qu'il a pas envie hein
ça ne passe pas
mais ouais donc fab il avait joué bas
contre maxime deux fois donne une
légende carrier qui n'avait fait nulle
verra nombre dès 2001 qui veut jouer sa
chronique 2007 ils vont tout 2007 mots
en 2005
donc
fait marrer ya un gars qui sait la redif
cc on dirait que le curé pour nom c'est
la rediff de la bd
bon en gros si tu veux que je te dise ce
qui se passe dans ces cahiers ces 3
bat avec lequel quatre cavaliers
français
3.952 me prend baisser alors bond en pro
b sat on pourrait se poser la question
mais ça va on va regarder la variante
déjà de vase
ok donc 17es b6
est à mon avis comme dirait vlad ça
commence que l' assaut contre leur gré
tassé d'état fou j'ai cinq
bons salaires relativement solide pour
les noirs évidemment mais
sa déposition de mag joue bien après un
non c'est pas trop à temps mais ça va là
dedans je crois est en train de devenir
ces dames 5
normalement baissées bon côté il ya dans
le premier set se joue à qui était la
base
mais normalement pas très grave
pas d'ailleurs c'est ça
l'ema calixte et chaud
bombay si son nom qui fait baver si ces
juges nouveauté mais bon ça paraît
tellement le seul coup que dame 17 au
foot on cavaliers web on peut être un
cousin de celui ci bizarre il n'y a pas
de prise de prise
parce que vous prendrez sagan la dame
mais
visuellement c'est moche pas très
logique quand même ces cinq c4 t'as pas
de pousser cette facilité c'est pourquoi
même temps peut-être bien aussi curieux
quoi
ouais même juste ça en fait ça donne pas
envie donc aller très loin à cause des
cinq
hommes il va faire baisser sa fausse
garantie peut il s'y fait baver si ce
jeu c'est pas un truc ils disent qu'il a
touché la dame
en tête qui l'a adoubé mais ici la
toucher l'objet du joueur
j'ai pas vu le moment en fait
s'il a touché ses morts il est obligé de
faire dame 17 et c'est peut-être perdu
non mais
je sais pas si quelqu'un un clip si vous
pouvez clip et ils peuvent revenir en
arrière et clip est comme ça on pourra
voir s'il a touché c'est fini en fait la
partie déjà perdu non mais
ce serait magnifique
lycéens chat
bon foot chute
il a perdu 10 la tête déjà doubin mais
si tu touches tadam étape a déjà double
tube judas jouer à bercy j'ai dit à jadu
à manier sa touche et sa dame avant de
prendre avec l'option 1 bah si vous avez
le clip c'est juste interdit
la double et lui aussi il faudrait le
clip pour s'en rendre compte ce qu'il a
pu a doublé la pièce
ça veut dire quoi ja double se dire je
replace ma pièce au centre de la case en
jeu la touche maj ajout pas ouais c'est
obligatoire si le jas doute n'est pas
dit on est obligé de jouer la pièce les
pièces jeu
on attend le clip on va on va se faire
notre avis fab on aura le ralentir avec
la voile à remettre à la loupe les temps
on va regarder on va regarder nous le
ralenti
saison oui mais ce qu'il a dit mais s'il
le dit pas c'est interdit
attends je replace
c'est vraiment une règle des échecs ça
si tu dis pas les cacher que je savais
eyeka chèvres mais j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il le dise
je pense qu'on tournoi si tu sais à
l'adversaire de demander mais je pense
que l'epo aurait pu demander le pièce
touché pièce à jouer
non mais ça se fait pas du tout c'est
pas correct ou quoi mais je veux dire
par là sion suit les règles de chez
suivre les règles je pense qu'il aurait
pu jeu ça va être un [ __ ] c'est
vraiment un truc d'enfoiré de demander
ça parce que tu vois qu'il adoube mais
si le dit pas
après bien des mecs qui ont monté des
gains en blitz parce qu'une place quitte
oui moi tu remets après
que j'aime pas ça quand l'esprit du jeu
donc b6 est décédé au caire mais contre
l'esprit du jeu mais je veux dire par là
que
dans ma vie sink au bon retour théorique
les amis je suis une partie mv-40 à 2017
il pas que nos richesses
un bon juste pour vous dire que j'en
avais ras mais la demande est bon à la
ces récitations théorique mais je pense
à turbo droit en fait tu as raison
tu attends ça juste rien en fait
il a voulu voir ce qu'il faisait sur
quatre oui
bon ok maintenant soit urbain soit à 4 à
4,5 me semble logique j'aime bien le
coup elle est à 4 l'idée c'est sûr d'un
pro b 5 apprend b52 fixé à 7 et
était plutôt
qu'à 5,5 en france comprendra pas de
laisser les
états c'est trop un peu faible à b6 un
peu faible
c'est un peu comme le bromontois album
tu reviens le cavalier de shalanaya f7
et à rien on chercher ici cette baie 5
je vais été changée en a et cedro
instante
à cuatro après c'est vrai qu'on a
peut-être fait une erreur en prélève
déjà annoncé que c'est la partie
terminée vite bas qui allait
jouer le title adobe du coup sont
peut-être
un messie d'apprendre il ya dans la base
d'un prend 1 puis on prend et à 5 oui
parce que si ça passe en fait c'est
drôme et un stand quoi 5,3 partir et
c'est peut-être de la corrèze a b c d
email chez eux jean-christophe contre
gagliardi virgilio
d'autres mecs par email et c'est que du
ce que des emails et c'est que des
drones
sa part pour sam adams en v5 la partie
pourrait vraiment duré moins d'une heure
aujourd'hui parce que dire viser la nuit
ça ne leur fait pas peur mais c'est
sûrement important soit 5 se jeter en
fait ces propos sa part au mon petit fab
900 fait c'est j'arrivais une partie de
2005 adams moreau et mon père ne voulait
pas pris la noc et qu'un maillage 4 si
tu vois que tu vois pas
alors que h quatre nouveautés il est
tous pro en passant les
les
unités à l'arrière pendant un bon ben
c'est déjà kf5 et puis tu va viser le
pion des 5 c par f5 le 3 ou tu feras g3
bon globalement temps et de faire g6 non
tu veux pas qu'ils viennent
et ce qu'il va te faire un g 3g quattro
j'ai quelque chose bon c'est la prépare
en tout cas là c'est la nouveauté
théorie
bon
j'essaie je suis quasi sûr qu'il va
faire
tu vas faire j'ai dit
ouais parce que peut-être qu'un rêve si
tu pourras le taquiner mon cadet sato
qui on va faire rédiger deux
g46 malgré tout
reto habite
à y croire et ça semble salle après toi
ok on sait ce 3g 5 et 17
qui prendrait cinq tours c4
qu'est ce que ce qu'ils ont peur des
problèmes pratiques sur mon ordi mais
zéro bien sûr mais ce qui est des
réseaux nomades des conneries
a déjà en attaque des 4 on a le plus
rapaces et un froid jamais négliger
celui-là
il ya même pas vraiment le réseau pour
le moment plus non mais vous
voyez tu alors dix tours
4 à 4 tours la poursuite n'ont
pas besoin c'est
fou ce qu'enfin 7 juillet salif hockey
parce que c'est hyper tous les coups
sont ultra logique en fait c'est assez
humain la variante qui est prend tout
reprend mais a
brillé avec force pour faire
un tour à 8,3 en f1 bon je parie que moi
je préfère une fois ci c'est quand même
très enfermé alors ils jouent les
oiseaux de maths mais c'est exactement
les coûts avec l'énoncé du coup je
voulais faire c'est déclic logic gaming
l'histoire une porte de sortie
et le truc c'est que je ne trouve pas
les coûts noir bizarre en fait j'ai si
c'est hyper logique ramène quai 17 ça
saoule qu'agile torres et vite c'est
logique car ali hafsi c'est logique tout
repenser 3 c'est logique faire j'ai
quatre en fait c'est que les gouttes
aurait joué en première intention mais
c'est peut-être ça le piège
peut-être que tu te dis oui enfin ça
peut pas être aussi simple du coup tu ne
vas y fais tu verras
n'oublions pas que ma news joue l'homme
par la position ouais mais là j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'avait pas l'idée
contre la petrov en fait qu'il espérait
autre chose il s'était dit silva dans
out of
on va voir
mais oui petite fessée que c'est
tellement simple
je troll mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
les coûts compliqué un nom c'est
vraiment tous les coups que tu as envie
de jouer
après peut-être que magnus à une feinte
à un moment attention nous là on a juste
regarder la variante principal
si vous les nuques directs seraient pris
en passant oui mais enfin disons que tu
veux quand même être un petit test même
si c'est pas dur donc tu veux pas ce pas
que tu veux pas nous le dire est que
c'est qu'en fait tu te dis bon j'ai 5 %
de chances de gagner 95 % nul au lieu de
100% autant prend des semaines pour s'en
prendre les 5 % mais c'est pas le truc
où tu dis j'ai et 40% des 1 40 % nuls et
20 % des fêtes là c'était dans l'ordre
du 95 5 ou 10 90 10 le 95 ou 97 ans la
drôme
on va voir un fab à la rigueur
après c'est parti là c'est pas des
partis qui sont vos chances étaient
partis qui sont parfaites à chaque fois
ça faut quand même le le souligner c'est
reconnu les temps le résultat le plus
probable ciné pause joue parfaitement
sera nulle part fait en fait
mais comme on dit j'ai six très logique
ce que les blancs qu'on vous dit il veut
faire cailler f5 gagner attention le
four il va se replacer vers 3 ou 7 et
taquiner l'option dessin et pour le
bouffer donc il faut éviter ce plan fait
ça qu'on veut faire 6
g6 effectivement ça empêche la case f5
aux cavaliers qui si une ferme h 4 pour
ça qu'on imaginait que les toucher aux
plongées pour repartir en g2 et un f4 ou
probablement en l'autre
après on nous a dit quelque chose
d'intéressant magie magie lota est vain
de penser que ce serait une âge d'or sur
e4 aussi tu as donc telle qu'ils ont
pensé que ce serait la nage d'art fait
que du coup il n'a pas une prépa de ouf
sur sur la petrov ça pourrait expliquer
bon après toute façon ce que je dois
dire c'est que
on peut pas afficher les petrov comme ça
quoi
non mais mais je veux dire par là que ça
a pas l'air d'être la tentative la plus
dingue que tu puisses avoir sur une
petrov quand même bonne claude juste
comme ça il ya des mecs qui ont fait de
tourner les machines pour leur 65e c'est
0-0
quand même des petites geo est
bon g6 jouer et on va voir si magnus
part surgit cap des turbines suis
peut-être le petit g3 plus conservateurs
si nous sommes un petit fois je suis
d'abord mais je sais pas trop l'intérêt
toute façon la tour vance évitant les
c'est clair et net c'est une bonne case
s'attaque le pion c3 une colonne normal
quoi tour hanoune a
joué une petite pub ah bah oui
j quattro
à une demi-heure de jeu c'était le
moment
j'ai quattro s'est on avait un qui a un
fils et ouais non mais pour répondre je
sais plus qui montre l'intérêt ou pas de
la petrov c'est une ouverture avec
laquelle tu as peu de chances de gain un
clébard mais c'est
très solide bloc solide comme les
rebelles
et donc voilà donc future affiche
clairement dans son jeu pour nulle
talent et noir tunique nuls ça me va
très bien et tu joues symétrique en fait
donc après faut que ça plaise un général
un truc ou
si les blancs
prennent pas de risque que tu vas jamais
pour gagner
il plusieurs micros avantage tombe était
un petit moment mais c'est une bonne
ouverture
mais qui
vont dire
qui n'est pas réputé fun
c'est pour ça que rien ne l'arrêté au
final on est peut-être marre
mais il a eu de bons résultats tel que
visé la nul ça lui faisait peur
ouais mais
en fait ce que je veux dire ce qui
s'était même qualifiée et gagner
candidats avec avec la petrov parce
qu'aussi les mecs conduite je vais un
peu lien genre la partie contre cramique
[Musique]
berlin c'est le party fun mairie
chronique près tous les risques étaient
très chauds met donc en fait tu peux
très bien contre avec la pègre qu'il
était mal d'ailleurs un sens oui mais
et donc il pouvait gagner des fois en
sus d'un gros de magnus les feuillets il
ya le matin en 30 ou quoi
il était vraiment introuvable ce bateau
c'est ma temps 49 of art of cards enfin
une bonne trentaine de fois bah oui non
à trouver trouver par hasard mais je
vais pas le voir à l'avancé c'était
introuvable
fait fallait cliquer au hasard et que ça
tombe bien
j'ai quatre bons manuscrits quand même
très bas à quoi tu vois là on est 19e
coup il continue quoi il connait tous il
récite
bon quai 17 ça paraît juste tellement
logique en fait peut-être que l'idée
c'est de faire une prépa qui a l'air
complètement inoffensif qui est vraiment
inoffensive et du coup tu vas tu ne sais
pas ce que ça peut être
une idée
il faut jamais faire confiance à
l'adversaire non c'est hyper important
échec à tous niveaux si tu vois pas
pourquoi tu veux pas faire ben tu fais
tant pis mais tant pis puis pierre tu
apprends bataille camus calculer c'est
tout mais faut pas dire vous me la jouer
ça et d'avoir une idée je ne peux pas
prendre
est de faire croire qu'il va s'inventer
une life mes impressions quand même
qu'il a une idée par partie oui
mais ils jouent pas au hasard comme cela
est prévu bon café petrov dont j'ai rien
mais débrouille-toi extrême à côté quand
à 15 secondes en totalité par partie
quand même ouais les poules a pas donné
l'impression d'avoir beaucoup d'idées
pour l'instant
elle a quand même eu le cavalier trois
c4
ah oui mais
une idée
le fait ni chaud ni froid mais il a une
contribuer dans la première partie il
était mieux n'est pas vrai mais il avait
pas d'idée en fait oui mais en fait
comme vivent là le problème c'est pas
des seconds allez que
mal géré même si ce cas d'ivan mais en
fait c'est vrai
a en tout cas venu s'est bien préparé
bon bah on sait enfin ce à chaque fois
les choses mais la dépouille connaît on
y va ça a l'air de lui faire ni chaud ni
froid aussi
qu'elle y réfléchisse un peu kitsch avec
mais peut-être qui connaît encore kg 2
j'ai envie de te dire quand ils sont
vraiment stressé et réfléchissent pas
4,5 parc où ils prennent une demi heure
là il tente pas du tout il s'en fout
d'eux
non mais peut-être qu'il ya un truc fin
plus loin ah oui ça c'est aussi ça c'est
possible mais pour le moment c'est pas
impressionnant
mais on sait pas quel truc fin bat
d'ailleurs
bon là il grandit à s'écailler f6 mais
si tu ferais un même toit et celui de
maintenance doit aller
tu ferais sept tours fc 8 je sais pas
pourquoi c'est réparé après je sais pas
après peut-être les blancs ils veulent
te faire fois efficace dans ses
positions
c'est une menace entre guillemets
d'échangés le fou il gagnera la caisse
de cette
île-etat avec des cinq et ils font des
choses
c'est parti quatre points f4 et point f
4 ans et 3 acquis et prend des cinq
tours des 3 mg à la taille de l'idée un
bon ben je sais pas moins
six ont pu s'arranger non non versa en
haut
et on fait de redonner encore on fait
deux jours de repos on fait des petites
soirées
foot
abbas a du coup été sali par adidas qui
font des très très belle soirée avec les
bonnes et on va faire semblant de jouer
avec le come back de machin un petit
message environnemental
mais cette soirée ce soir son
anniversaire il ya les petites chicha
qui part ils sont très heureux qu'en
fait ses meilleurs amis du monde juste
après oui je veux dire en conférence de
presse j'étais vraiment sous pression
puis après grosse soirée quoi
ce serait magnifique de riec maxime qui
est la jules fatah les soirées de génie
quoi
me demanda mvl directement c'était cuit
qui en cas tous les soirs le tabac qui
sur place tequila passer des coups de
fil ou quoi c'est magnifique
bons tours fc s'est un peu moins précis
kéfi sans qu'il y ait de drame
je sens que qui avait le fleuve qui
appartient
toujours recette mais en fait ça peut
être armé des petits machins
scientifique cavaliers machin cavaliers
cheikh
jusqu'à 2,7 et 2,8 des sine qua
non mais
ça peut paraître tu te dis que peut te
tiens ton écoute est rien
je sais rien à voir en tout cas ce qu'on
regarde être ta leur qualif 6 d'abord si
ce machin ça me semble bien bien bien
la
norme sd peugeot vite voilà ce qui joue
vite comme d'hab c'est bien mais je sens
qui connaît là je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
l'intuition qui sait ce qu'il a pas la
fin mais il est petit site match.com
d'yves l'admets là il a pas l'air d'être
impressionné du tout regarde c'est pour
ça que j'ai laissé la caméra sur lui
parce que
le regard il a regardé genre en mode
mais je fais quoi frère qu'est ce tu
veux quoi
non mais c'était vraiment ça genre je
connais frérot
on à l'arrêt à 18 heures bon plus pop
mais là c'était vrai c'est vraiment le
regard qu'il a jeté un on est d'accord
femmes c'est pas moi qui ai carrément
honteux c'est vraiment genre
ça fait penser à aulas donc là je ne
vous pas comme mon frère qu'est ce que
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire
c'est
tekki ouais bof wave 4
10 pouces series les chiffres chez
hédiard harissa les seconds en date
s'est allumé le sonnac
je switche de carrière mais j'ai chopé
vraiment pile au bon moment le switch de
gamme
il veut finir vite pour jouer le titre
ah bah oui ils savent que le presse va
jouer
vraiment réduire le temps des partis
c'est pas possible or ben non c'est
dommage après ça serait quand même
dommage
non
on serait moins sur
unibet aide en qui seront parqués sur le
nul au haut les frérots ce qu'ils ont
lieu on va mettre un petit à petit sans
cassure la drôme toutefois cette belle
soirée je suis prêt à me prennent 10 20
noms ne suis pas là nul à combien les
côtés mais si elle à 1,30 1,40 m 30000
tous les jours quoi mais bon je les
steaks andorre et trente mille fois à
14,2 feront un petit 400 milles en plus
et tu dis oui mon sens rapide ou
peut-être ils jouent les partis eux
la veille la veille où pend un jour de
repos on se fait des parties en une
heure chaos et on décide à la fin qui
viennent la dernière quoi bon
bon
en gros noms mais il va essayer un truc
personnes bien sûr on trop long trop
long 3 le sait c'est du second degré
évidemment qu'ils jouent mais juste
manque d'idées quoi
en 33 sur le nybot pas mal
mais bon pas avant aujourd'hui je sais
pas tu réalises en général c'est logique
de médecins va tu as déjà à 16 heures
consécutives
17 17 on est à 17 c 18 18 manificat
entre lire des rampes de boxe pour
secouer un peu les méninges aime ça
existe déjà le chat botté
un peu décevant le match et n'ont pour
l'instant brawn on sait ce qu'on attend
vrai c'est ce qu'on attendait jusqu'à
maintenant non mais s'il est décevant
c'est un peu des deux premières voilà
parti à l'ehpad et secondes ça pour
l'instant après la cie juste y viennent
avec des grosses prépare et que c'est
nickel s'est blindée c c'est ce qu'on
attend en face et y être eu six mois
pour bosser voilà ils récitent leur
travail c'est du bon boulot
et bravo et voilà
les deux premières citées potable
la seconde était plus spectaculaire mais
ouais mais c'est normal si on passait
quand même beaucoup de temps à se
préparer c'est pas facile de rentrer
dans un match quant à fait normalement
je comprends que c'est pas facile mais
c'est pas pour autant que peut pas dire
que dommage
non mais clairement clairement ça
clairement on est d'accord
mais bon
ah si mauvais intrigue
c'est juste pas spectaculaire mais ça
c'est un autre débat mais en terme de
jeu là aujourd'hui s'ils font nul comme
ça sera une bonne partie n'est pas bien
préparés magnus bas chantal est truqué
mais on peut être qu'il va enfin
bon faut pas oublier un carlson c'était
typique son style d'avoir pas grand
chose
faire jaillir de l'eau un caillou quoi
ouais
alors qui sait on va voir
finalement semaine particulière le feu
sur l'échiquier mais bon il faut être
quatre prochains cases noires à voir
avec ça la case de cette jarre pour la
tour de calais qui va s'auto f4 va
attaquer des cinq qu'elle n' horizon
bien sûr le pion passé à
c'est pas tout simple en fait ce qui se
passe
donc il peut chose voici une époque
connaît tous eh ben il va réciter et il
arrivera l'année mais si doit un peu
défendre une pression pas si simple
d'ailleurs la disait que c'était
peut-être un des points faibles
défendre les positions bordélique ça va
ses dents sont
clairement danser dans ce qu'il peut
faire mais défendre un temps précis
enregistrons beaucoup il fait pas en
fait
bien caché
soit bien sûr deuxième épaisseur
sur le queen baez et puis
prise en passant ainsi l'opéra continue
d'avancer chez nora n'ont appris la
naissance et j'ai maintenant ou jamais
laisser continuer à jouer à 5 il fallait
prendre immédiatement un
pas plus loin
l'uni valdingue bas je crois que c'est
pas fait pour être discret tu veux faire
de la pub pour que ça soit n y en a deux
sacres miens et remonte en a qu'un mais
là il y en a deux sabots cette semaine
la troisième
parce que jamais deux sans trois
vallées pâte rodrigues pourrières beau
il dit pas trop contente au niveau de
jeu
mais il ya pire
pas de chance je prends pas 130 coups
après la finale
la fura yvon à 2h tiens je te prends
déjà la relève là ils vont vers des
options à 2 je veux plus le voir
du tout rapide à quel point vous pensez
que ça réduire lé nul bas il suffit de
voir le match de speed chaudière par
exemple il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de nuls
un peu trop
rapide y en aurait aussi beaucoup moins
mais bon après
c'est un championnat du monde le k2
qu'annonce classique donc c'est normal
que ça sue franck la transe classique
entre guillemets un peu l'intitulé du
des rires oui non non mais en fait fin
juste pour vous dire
fois de plus c'est pas grave fier des
nuls quoi la normale quand la partie
bien jouer de parts et d'autres
on veut pas partir à la chasse est
forcément camacho non
donc c'est rien
voilà après on aime bien quand les
partis se passe des trucs ça veut
spectaculaire ça joue bien il ya du bien
nul on aime bien aussi quand ça gagne
que 1 j'aurais poussé à l'erreur et
après ça pourrait débrider le match
parce que j'étais obligé de prendre des
risques pour revenir et voilà ça serait
ça sera autre chose mais pour l'instant
on fait juste personne ne veut lâcher de
terrain personne nous prendre trop de
risques ça s'entend pourquoi la prise en
passant uniquement avec les pions ça je
peux l'expliquer oui moi aussi mesures
je pense très bien expliqué et en gros
ce parce qu'il ya très longtemps les
pions d'avancé que d'une case et pour
accélérer les parties on a décidé de
permettre pour le premier coup
déplacement d'un pion d'avancer de deux
cases et pour accélérer le déroulement
des parties civiles zoe3 aussi sous 4 5
c'est ça il y aura des besoins position
c'était long quoi et donc ils ont pris
la décision de changer le premier un
coup d'options et de permettre permettre
d'avancer de deux cases mais ils sont
rendu compte qu'ils aient des finales de
pions ou y avait par exemple un pion h4
et que les blancs pouvaient faire j'ai
quatre et qu'un pion pouvant dépasser un
autre et esquiver une prise et donc pour
empêcher que ce soit possible ils ont
permis quand ce pur avant de deux cas ce
qu'ils soient pris par un autre pion
c'est pourri bel équilibre en fait fait
de la position de la partie
j'ai juste fait pas à 5 tu dégages les
tours à toi tu fais un petit truc est
illustratif la
presse que tu voulais faire
les crocs f1
comme ça avec les vieilles règles pour
les blancs se disent ok j'essaie de
faire des trucs à l roi mon pions b5 il
esafe il pourra jamais poussé somptueux
au silence d'une case the le beauf et
puis voilà et puis à onglet nord fin
annoncée de ce côté tout va bien sauf
que finalement
avec des nouvelles règles bâle nord pour
se dire ah bah je fais à 5/8 à 3 2 me
bouffer et puis bah je vais au bout je
vais gagner vous avez introduit la prise
en passant pour interdire ce truc est là
bas ne
bouffe est fait il faut lutter vraiment
bloquer quoi et voilà c'était juste pour
équilibrer
la règle dans cette d'occase au départ
pourquoi qu'avec un pion bas c'est
justement parce que bahia klaus fait
sens ça fait ça
ça avait quand ce changement devrait
gros ça je sais plus d'un siècle
ils ont des reflets 2 case rsa
mais la rive fait sens
et plombe pas reculer non
interdite
donc imaginez inoffensif avec les blancs
c'est dur d'être offensif est clément en
réalité un mais la partie d'avant il
était très offensif comme juste ça fait
se retourner contre lui et là bon ça a
beau être objectivement et gagnent je
sais pas si ça va vraiment faire nul si
facile
il n'a pas l'air d'être ce qu on les
pendra prépare un jeu non
on pourrait imaginer une nouvelle
modification majeure ou mineure des
règles après tant d'années de pratique
avant et actuellement je vois pas de
changement de règle
arriver mais
[Musique]
ça peut arriver un
interdiction de la burqa noz
non sérieusement je sais pas
il avait rééquilibré le veut quand même
les cadences ça peut être une option le
960 ça peut en être une autre voix y
rentrer dans ce qu'on a vu un web revend
en tout le temps de la partie le pense
uniquement à la partie parfois ils vont
penser à autre chose on pense en faire
demain robots ils vont penser à autre
chose à un certain moment vaudrait mieux
pas mais en fait tu peux pas mon esprit
divague à certains
l'ajout avant de noter les coûts aïe aïe
aïe je crois que tu as le droit d'avoir
un deuxième coup de retard ouais
note 1 coûte une note un couteau
les pièces sont vraiment belles ces cas
le modèle je crois que c'est un modèle
f5 bas qui le vend le modèle sayan il
les a reçus dans les airs et vous pouvez
les trouver sur alpha échec
alors cette tour on a regardé autour des
3 pour attaquer le pion un peu logique
c4 s'attaquerait au silence mais nous
aurons une fourche hatcher
b61 à la turbine dans un truc marrant
mais je suis passé sera quelque chose
tour f
3,3 g autour des 3
es tu sais qu
peut-être tomber trois
ans j'aurais juste les turbines chirac
on préfère 54,6 dû tomber trois recettes
qualifie je sais pas je peux la suite
bon je veux dire pluton detroit -
mais c'est moi
même c'est quand cette variante a pas
tort quand v5 et c7 j'étais en train de
montrer avec tarbes et
3,3
à badens mots
donc ça veut dire que il a joué tour des
trois trains aller-retour est repu
logique ce que c'est là marion n'a pas
idée il est plus logique
ce tour cette cavale et f8 cavale et
appuie 6,3 g 7 des cinq cavaliers 8
ranger éviter 5 ça paraît logique mais
du coup tu as si tu veux pas faire tout
reprendre et cinq ans d'étroite et bien
frais après avec tours b 3 le coup
c'était pour bekaert pour venir attaquer
g4 pas suffi retour des cadres tous les
travailleurs des quatre et qui m ont
écouté je pense aux avoirs sans âme
étourdis qui
fait toujours recette cavalia fille tu
crois j'ai eu un bug mais ouais ce qu'on
a vu
et à la fin après des cinq
probablement l'a4
je pense magnus il connaît encore un oui
mais je sais pas si j'arrive pas à
comprendre si c'est dangereux ou pas
bon
on veut faire peux vous dire que les
ordis disques serial
dépôts soient effrayés en fait mais lors
du tout
peut-être qui connaît aussi pour une
raison x ou y
non mais il doit copains
je sais pas vu
arriver lâche 4 ce qui est intéressant
que je regarde les ordis 6 en parle
en fait c'est clair qu'après a5b prend
ainsi c'est le meilleur coup mais qui
fait annuler les votes par
correspondance était forcément prêts
dessus et donc ces noms qui choisit pour
dévier même idée pratique
ce qu'il a essayé de faire comme depuis
le début du match en fait il ya cinq et
une petite idée le caillou 7 qui sait si
ce qui est peut-être pas petit qui
égalise et être complètement sur la
ligne de trois mondes et le caillou 5
direct
mais qui avait 10 h 4 tu vois là bon
juste à pouvoir 34 et j'ai pas 35 allégé
pas mis pendant quatre jours le truc le
puis je parle je fais deux minutes et
c'est pas mon top 3 des coûts cléac'h 4
juste un coup tu peux ne pas regarder
si c'est un bon second temps il peut
tchèque pas si noir cavaliers h quatre
accusés qui se trouve maintenant c'est
ça et mais magnus ils sont pas mal son
équipe pour le faire des trucs comme ça
à chaque fois à chaque fois chaque fois
et est donc la position résultante qu'on
a là
écoute
[Musique]
il s'est dit ok je suis calme gérer sans
pratique ça me flatte bcm
après je ne sais pas à quel point ils
connaissent en fait si je suis un peu
leur dise qu'ils racontaient c'était
patois fc8 au maintien c'était plutôt
d'abord qu'est f6 donc peut-être juste
il connaissait la ligne à six je sais
pas jusqu'où et qu'il savait que si
c'est autre chose c'est un poil
inférieur mais ça n'a pas l'air grave
non plus mais que ne s'était pas le test
le plus critique entre guillemets
bon
allez on méga dangereux car ici ce
précepte qui a eu trois j'évite avions
un tel fonds d'état qui ont acquis
passer ta case 17 surtout un je vais
leur expliquer oui la case 17 elle est
créée bien obstruant j'ai bien blindé
et s'il ya vraiment besoin internautes
pour 2015 enfin là les cases des 8 et 17
elles sont ultra blindés
bon après tu peux avoir envie de faire
qu'il prend b6 ou deux il a le rôle de
faire des propositions
justes donc trop dénudées 8 tu vas y
revient en dessin et en prendre les 5 ce
que tend un piège aux
femmes aux autres de sinko
peut-être que tu es plus content que la
tour soit pas à
pousser le pion à je ne sais pas bon
après ça encore échanges l'action de
plus alors forcément
faire à
4,5 on va y arriver non mais bon a
priori pas de gros danger pour dépôt n'y
a pas vraiment de mêlées blanc en fait
ce qu organiser des fins là une nouvelle
fois quand tu fais des six au pire bon
là j'ai tout rangé 4 mai même si tu fais
à 4,7 au pire à ronger qu'un retour des
cinq
étaient bien oui noms des huit là tu me
tais loin de le mener afin que tu es
loin de faire des sets et du coup une
fois que tu as fait dix-sept fois encore
menacer des 8 c'était vraiment très loin
de le faire et moi je suis à tour à 5 à
3 2 qui mobilise des atours et aura plus
rien pourra plus passer
ça paraît quand même archi nul ça nous
rêvent mais bon à voir après c'est vrai
que tout purgé quatre ans tu peux te
content de te dire si ge à l'étranger 5
je plante le cheval en ifsi les petits
réseaux
mais
s'ils croient pas en partie l'entente
fait le con tre jeu du miroir il va
tellement vite fait et quand même à jeun
2 3 4 ou 4 parce que le cinquième il est
sûr et chaque on était à quatre coups en
fait de gagner avec les noirs donc avec
les blancs puis bon une fois que tu as
fait g5 cavalli m6 est loin de menacer
matin n'ont peut-être et maintenant le
gers et des idées plus de blitz en face
que de
vernet hypo faudra peut-être sur un coup
franc qu'il le fasse je sais que le
tempo mais ça c'est dans ses cordes
ça sent la turbo d'euros
oh ça ferait plaisir pas parce qu'on va
pas se le cacher un bas surtout que ça
permettrait de faire le title quoi un
oui ça permet à baky de faire le title
ça permet aux gens d'or vient le temps
de prendre le livre dédicacé abbaoui de
passer les commandes tout cela bien
comme il faut
non c'est parfait petit nul rapide nous
on souffle
alors on se fait bien un jour de repos
hier avant sous plafond enfin quoique
jours de repos hier soir à pacy souffler
que ça hein c'est pour ça c'est le
speech chasser tous les problèmes
internes à aujourd'hui alors je me
demande si j'ai mon planning du prochain
switch est
un bon match hier quand même assez sympa
et sympathique il ya eu une action plus
joueurs français avant ce speech à sion
d'un qui est tchétchène fils s'est juste
fait éliminer par il n'avait pas fait
ligne en pâtit je ne viens pas et
l'autre s'est fait éliminer au premier
tour donc nos deux stars françaises
éliminé du speech est championship
depuis
journée
à la seconde à la nanoseconde bah oui
non mais c'est le petit parti sans pas
moi je préfère voir ça que ça dure une
heure et demie plus tôt que tomber dès
qu'un truc qui dure quatre heures et où
tu sais pertinemment des débuts qui se
passe rien - là une petite idée ça joue
un peu sa marche pas tu as 15 heures on
t'a dit à mon avis non mais ça te fait
plaisir mais je suis pas sûr ça fera
fini à 15 heures non mais quitte à faire
une d'oro un peu insipide je préfère
qu'elles soient turbo
au moins on est heureux tout le monde
ait connu heureux les gens sont heureux
on est heureux car ce n est heureusement
et je fais des chiens adversaires et les
arbitres sont heureux quand une belle
bon feu de façon la rue leur logo il est
caché derrière les belles sont pas si à
l'avenir on sera comme genre remettront
leur reste ils seront très heureux de
voila je vous sais d'ailleurs pas
longtemps à tien
[Musique]
highlight de la journée ça il a remis ça
reste donc magnifique donc quand ils
baissent de re aussi phosagro toujours
heureux la fille des heureux
soit on trouve là de moyens parce que
bon hein et nostra blasius jeudi à eux
[Musique]
bon rien à dire tu sais qui vivent avec
2 tél
tout le monde est heureux
à plus de gestes comme moi peut-être
afaq safin en une heure
on dure eux-mêmes et mais si heureux msi
très heureux de tout sera tout aussi dur
on crache du feu de partout
il aurait voulu voir un dragon à mon
avis aujourd'hui
et ont du coup ils disent oui il me
regardait petrov vraiment une très
mauvaise verture wagon
d'ailleurs malgré le fait que je ne dois
pas kamil plonger si ce bon il a pas
compris ce film est le fou mais c'est un
début alors peut-être la suite
telle qu'elle protège la peau ni le
héros aussi plus gros coup heureux
n'empêche qu'à une baisse dont on parle
beaucoup plus depuis des cachets à 13h20
ouais enfin c'est le bonheur son agent
de bonheur mais les dropt façon ça rend
toujours les gens heureux et pas de
perdants et a pas de perdant ce qui est
bon famille
à lewandowski pas
ici non mais je veux dire en fait
ils sont si vous en avez dit savait
qu'il allait pas gay voilà tu prévient
le lauréat avant de conclure versailles
qui avait pas y aller quand même venu à
la remise dont tu vois si tu es si les
goûters que ça elle est boudée qu'il
était assez classe d'ailleurs il est
heureux
lui l'ami ces petites bicyclette la
semaine dernière il te dit vas-y
j'encourage chercher ligue des champions
puis dont pipeau de ballon d'or
mais bon le rêve pour nous subsistent en
plus le rêve des 14 euros abbas a oui on
y croit encore en fait si on arrive là
cap donc n'est pas rien et clément
prochaine 5 carlson souffle 6me match
non ça peut c'est leur top 14 ben arfa
c'était 12 et on pouvait faire 14 ce
serait ce serait beau à prêcher patients
y arriver record battu non mais on n'y
croit pas trop
on n'y croyait pas du tout le reste
arrive quand même à 4 tu
commence alors un petit espoir
quand même tu coules enfin tu commences
entre voiron 4t pas très confiant mais
si on arrive à 7,8 tu commences arrivé
là bas
il faut 14 et je vous rends des parties
rapides départageront
sais pas si c'est moi j'imagine pas à 14
nuls mais bon pour l'instant j'y crois
pas trop mais c'est un rêve
quatorze rhône et port reviendrait sur
fil rouge tu vois
ça aussi c'est pas trop patient son
objectif
on voit les coûts on veut juste qu'on
jette un petit oeil sur la turbine dans
le sens où comme c'est des prépas et que
les voir en l'occurrence ont tous
regardé alors dit on checke pour voir si
ça suit et comme les coûts sont plus ou
moins forcé en fait voilà il a plusieurs
choix il peut les prendre b6 fait
recaler f6 peut peut-être tourner des
scènes je sais pas quoi
pas le prévenu pu ranger 4 pour le coup
en fait c'est juste que surtout reprend
des quatre vingt neuf ans dirige la
guinée touchable quoi sur échec donc là
on préfèrerait que son g3 en fait à ce
moment là soit changée 5 mai
nous proposer d'air froid dans le tchat
je tourne et 85 des ventes d'actions
avaient passé mais bon mais tu aurais
pas très beau mais attendez le toit fiat
arrive y parvenir la colonne b après bon
peut-être magnus peut-on tessa
1 2 3 4 5 et
les noirs ils sont quand même deux coups
tombent et et
caillau 6 qui rebondit au sol
fraîchement c'est sans risque pour les
noirs ça fait faut qu'il faut qu'ils
germanophone la bon là c'est sûr
maintenant qu'il connaît plus
peut-être que déjà depuis depuis tour
ses huit d'ailleurs et
à voir et c'est sûr qu'il a rien
c'est comme ça
non mais là petrov
les trouve pas mal on va le bric mans
c'est que je me questionnais depuis
un bon moment en fait pourquoi on la
voyait plus trop rocard n'avait raté au
final il n'y a pas de raison je suis
voulait plus faire parce qu'ils
voulaient plus faire
comme sa femme un
bo kay passé un truc intéressant à
prendre enfin sa
alors est-ce que magnus dans une partie
va sortir 2 6 4
epub
j'ai aussi deux des quatre à joba bas
je pense pas qu'il fera
vaka et ses trois au deuxième aussi
non mais c'est
dès l'ouverture c'est solide mais je
pense qu'il aura plus d'opportunités
s'il retourne vers des 4
et peut-être ça rien de revenir là
dessus sauf s'il a vraiment à ses quatre
branches bien sûr
peut-être à faire comme toi un couche un
coup pas rond et après on revient dans
le sens inverse
et heureux
dans le trip
bah je sais pas je sais pas
koné paulien on a eu à rester vraiment
exclusivement sur quatre ouais bon sauf
s'ils menaient au score et que peut-être
il a besoin d'amener des parties plus
théorique et encore ça dure dribbler
carlson mais
tu te dis bon je sais quelque chose de
plus loufoques
j'avais 4
ans
les joueurs quand ils progressent on
tactique et à un moment il adore faire
des menaces avec des
dépendances mais il faut que ça lui
l'utile à l'agréable et là
malheureusement sa paire de pions mais
c'était vraiment on a tous été tenté
quand on a commencé à être un peu plus
affûté en tacticien serge québec est
aussi tu commences à avoir ces coups là
tu es heureux en fait il faut l'utiliser
à bon escient ce truc-là genre là après
cavalli m6 qui a valu 8 tu peux faire
des 5 tu le défends par fourchette ses
tactiques là faut les utiliser à bon
escient fait comme zidane avec ses
roulettes les ai
pas pour les faire au visiteur n'avait
pas d'adversaires autour
c'est sa part passé la partie depuis le
début
ar mais lentement quand on me demande
c'était une petrov hyper torride façon
on fera on fera le résumé de la partie 1
comme toujours
une fois qu'elle sera terminée
un résumé qui pourrait être le plus
rapide finalement aujourd'hui fab
peut-être pour le moment sa part four
mais
parti ultra théorique
mais ça et même 17 à quatre reprises 5
bien joué enlève le pion arriérés cash
qui est la nouveauté mais n'est pour
agir c'est vite
et de manière assez logique
on voit que le pion des cinq à attaquer
mais il s'est vengé sur ces trois
parfois de ce qu'on a vu je me demande
si tu la joues ça peut même pas à
devenir risqué pour les blancs perso
j'aurais été en partie j'aurais pris nul
instance la sortie au fisc et 8 leurs
trompettes moi j'aurais fait ça on peut
être qu'il va faire j'aurais été
pleutres non mais je me serais dit que
j'en ai marre de cette partie mais je
sais pas ce pion à je la mets
un truc marrant c'est quand on regarde l
au début j'étais un hyper si ça j'aime
pas considérer ne pas le prendre
césar de laisser ce truc donc là
honnêtement j'aurais joué en partie mais
ce genre 100% sûr je réfléchis ce qui a
valu durée j'aurais pu vous le voir
cette partie en fait je serais dit
l'option il va commencer à passer le
mien 17 je vais jamais y arriver au pire
ivan claquer le cheval il va partir pour
faire ça ça va être dangereux pour moi
tant pis je prendre aux honnêtement moi
j'aurais pris d'euros
ça peut passer c'est logique toi tu
aurais fait quoi je sais pas mais juste
et pas compte qu'ils jouent aussi mais
admettons un gars de ton niveau
mais imaginons que tu joues contre moi
on va peut la jouer
ça dépend le vélo de l'adversaire sur le
tournant d'un mec à 25,25 40 à ton
niveau je veux dire fatigue d'une
part moi j'aurais faire très très
honnêtement j'aurais pris l'alluré sa
mort est saoulé en fait parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui me fait peur je
avant vos
faut aussi jugé un peu ton espérance de
gain quoi c'était quasi sûr tu vas pas
arriver à gagner que juste eu à prendre
des risques autant faire ne l'ont lâché
l'impression que si je joue pour le gain
je prends des risques
après c'est moi c'est mon niveau de con
j'ai pas eu tous niveaux de carlson donc
vite peut-être il va trouver des idées
mais vraiment emballé s'adapter à notre
jeunesse option g4 qui n'en est plus
très bien il ya ce pion à qui passe dès
que je prends b si je me rends tourbe et
de façon je vais le perdre le pion elle
qui a et qui peut rejaillir en russie
c'est gênant mais ça me fait j'aurais
tant perez a déjà avec les blancs
samarie en pls
6 3 6 3 je suis descendu ce qu'on
regarde peter martin que cela il met va
te faire à saint à quatre a321
bon c'est ce combat en fait ces joueurs
on est d'accord un article peu mais bon
- faites ça me réussit sa mort amy en
pls g5 à trois cavaliers f6 3g 7
h 4 il va me faire faire à deux
je sais pas ça m'aurait mis en pl ace
peut-être tout re 2 e ici encore avec
des systèmes non je ne sais pas
j'aurais pris peur
d'ailleurs il peut se racheter avec en
premier pour bientôt bloqués comme il
faut
je me serais pas vu la gagner
je vois que le redis a des idées mais on
leur dit tu fais quoi il te fait roi g2
pour des deux tours b 7
à 2 tombé 6 10 ans
mais c'est pas si simple à coeur ouais
ben hadj a tout fait griller un pion
un sac car ça n'est capable de mettre
cette idée là j'aurais raté
et là tu peux perdre
tient compte leur dis j'aurais perdu là
ça j'avais pas vu jouer mais quoi avec
les noirs et jouer ses coûts avec les
bleus en fait
où j'ai perdu en fait jusque là ça va ça
ça allait je sens que je reste dauphin
moi j'aimais bien parce que je me sens
unique et h7
peut-être virage 6
pour recy de mines et j'ai cinq mois
n'a pas suffi à vii mais jack lord est
content
à ok bon
il peut voir me we
bleed si on pense qua non mais en partie
ici c'est vraiment chiant
en ya peut-être de quoi être ici ou là
un truc à faire des petits pièges des
petites idées
ça défend bien ça défend bien et puis
c'est tout il ya des petites idées pour
les blancs moi je les aurais pas vu
perso sa mort est saoulé mais j'avais
pas le tombé c'est tombé six tours à 6
en fait si j'avais eu cette idée là
j'aurais pu jouer donc ça dépend si je
spot ça en partie là je la joue au
magnus un magnifique oui oui c'était
juste pour parler de ce qu'on aurait
nous fait un fab mais c'est quand même y
avoir encore d'autres trucs mais plutôt
à
ce que tu me coupe la liaison entre la
tour à 8 et le pion à
et en cas d'échangé avions passé toi
même et c'est
jacques boivin qui secoue recommandé
pour centrer dans le calcul badens faire
en fait plus on en fait plus à rien tu
calcules tu calcules tu calcules et une
touche pas les pièces tu fais tout dans
la tête
il même si tu y arrives pas tu forces et
petit à petit demi coup par dominique
août ira plus loin un jour tu vas a
plafonné mais c'est la vie
déjà tu iras ton max comme ça
non je pense qu'il va la jouer enfin que
lui va la jouer je retire parce que j'ai
dit moi je n'aurais pas joué lui va la
jouer
au niveau de profondeur j'aime tels que
car ces données peut atteindre à nice où
le focus
mais en fait
ça peut aller très loin mais le truand
requis six échecs jouer
ça peut aller très loin
le truc faut distinguer finalement deux
types de position c'est soit ceux des
lignes très longue très fort sentent tu
peux aller très loin en fait
soit à des positions tu vas pas
forcément très loin mais c'est beaucoup
plus flou parce qu'il ya plein d'options
parts et d'autres dont tu peux voir ça
comme un arbre très longiligne ou un
autre une sorte de buissons et
d'aviation de partout et deuxième truc à
dire le but ce n'est pas de faire un
exploit de calcul plus impossible mais
c'est finalement arrivé à un moment où
tu es capable de juger la position est
que si tu joues pour l'avantagé que tu
vois que la position de la juge mieux et
qu'il joue avec précision à saana les
voir encore plus loin c'est ta santé
mieux tu es content dans cette position
et et voilà si tu prends nul tu vas être
gay gal ba ça ne suffit pas besoin
d'avoir encore quel scoop gers est
encore bien égal ou voilà après ce qui
est dur c'est de bien juger et de voir
loin
voilà on va avoir droit g71 c'est sûr
donc voilà ça je vais en fait ils sont
calmes et de quel pied très loin ça
dépend quelle position ça dépend quand
j'ai des ramifications possibles partout
et le degré de complexité
et dernier truc le but c'est par votre
calcul plus loin possible mais juste de
bien juger poser un bon jugement sur la
position
7 m pour un rageux suite c'est injouable
à tourcoing f7
il s'asseoir il a cliqué
qu'avait lieu le 8 ca va etre tempo
d'ailleurs truc marrant tu peux
peut-être là qu'est la cale
en réalité tu as peut-être ça aussi
moi j'aime pas trop mal être
mais si tu gagnes ça étudiants c'est
tintin a basculé 2 tu penses à vienne
lui dire situation et exterminent
tonnelle dame me suis mal exprimé
non c'est vrai que le fait d'attaquer
attaquer
si j'aurais rentrer là dedans non non
en fait votre sur l'extermination bien
fait bref 3 est-ce qu'on a autre chose
mais tu vas pas exterminer un ballon
d'essai mais on est juste mais je trouve
ce qu'on peut faire tomber quatre plus
tôt
mais bon je vais quand même me grâce à
thierry siens thirith
oui
pas le faire donc là il va faire cavaler
8 tempo nepos est quand même relevé
en réalité la juste comparer pour pour
parler un peu du mouvement des joueurs
comme on fait tous les jours elle est là
les joueurs en fait il pourrait jouer
tempo on perd on perd du temps pour rire
là parce que j'avais des outils le fait
tempo fin il aurait était assis en face
c'était roger 7ème pour cavaler 8 tempo
on a perdu combien de temps y avait des
six a perdu une minute 50 pour jouer sa
retenue de 30 e oui et on va en reperdre
encore 30 à perdre quatre minutes sur ce
petit échange jusque là les coûts sont
forcés et roy g8
ont ça va il est là en fait ils rient
sirois 6
9 7
en fait d'un
abandon
fait la main
vers auch 6 qui s'est
dessiné dessus mais la fourchette haute
des tours
et donc ça apporte rien je pense qu'il
faut acheter
sauf si tu dis tiens je rentre mais bon
c'est bizarre de 6,7 en l'air tout le
temps et qu'on panique à l'idée droit h6
cdci avait sur des cinq qui reprend des
symboles cavalli m6 échec et du coup
c'est interdit dès 5000 problème c'est
que ça n'interdit pas à cause de crise
est
donc les deux là seul lot de vraies
options c'est on prend 8 mai a tellement
pas de raison de le faire
après quand tu calcules en partie moi
j'aurais été capable d'envoyer une cale
et j'aurais pu perdre à cause de ça 9 ce
t-shirt sur mer ça j'aurais pu
l'envisager un petit peu
bon
en
fait le problème de sa cuisse de cap
chat ne te dire tu es tu sens c'est
possible et tu le ferais si dans l'autre
était vraiment moins bien mais en fait
en jouant normal tu vois pas que témoin
bien raté pas mal et on n'a pas le fait
qu'on ne t'a pas de raison de
éventuellement toute l'année karlsson
clairement il y pensant à la nulle celui
là il série a si boire un peu d'eau l'aï
c'est que ce soit des cinq soit nulle
autre chose encore je sais pas peut-être
cet ours et un
sa courbe à
80 tours projet 93 c'est trop c'est sûr
on va toujours en fait cette position
semble y aura peut-être des
compensations en retour à deux mais
c'est vraiment mal
assurée parti pour quatre
gros et tant pis
ça tu accomplie donc alors j'avais
révisé la nage lors ce matin parce que
j'avais écouté vlad
qui disait joué que des quatre du coupon
pour une raison x ou y j'ai voulu voir 4
quand même en espérant une halte dorff
rêve non exaucé rêve non exaucé je
craignais la petrov j'avoue j'avais
envie de vous fin je savais que dans la
petrov je n'avais pas l'idée donc j'ai
révisé la nage dorff à fond en disant si
senna jorf au moins j'ai quelque chose
va j'ai tenté c'est pas aller dans la
direction que je souhaitais la petrov
j'avais ça mais je savais qu'il y avait
rien et nex gagné
ce qu'elle veut dire si t'as rien trouvé
de concluant dans la petrov n'a pas de
raison d'avoir révisé comme un ouf pour
de toute façon rien à voir
donc je pense que tu tentes un bluff tu
dis ok je vais vraiment réviser le
fichier
si je trouve je fais mal donc tu voues
celui-là tu mets tout dessus et si ça
tombe pas dessus tu t'es face la partie
après c'est un aveu de faiblesse dans un
match d'arrêter de jouer si vite au
blanc mais bon faut pas être têtu et
s'entêter pour rien non plus pas faire
de lego va le servir c'est comme ça que
carl scène s'est mis à perdre contre car
yakine d'ailleurs au blanc à trop
vouloir
être qu'il a retenu les leçons du passé
de toute façon pour le moment il a eu
deux fois les noirs c'est ça 2 c'est sa
deuxième partie avec les blancs donc
s'il fait nul il revient juste un crime
de trucs qui en quatre parties et tu
fais championne allemande en 10 parties
avec quelques indications
tu sais qu'il jouera pas les gones
feltus alexis toujours pas l'adage nov
parce que la peau du cac qui se mange
moi je la mange pas mais vous non plus
ou par accident si la base non
mais ce doit songer
soit on dit que dans les fruits il ya
plein de vitamines dans la peau juste en
dessous
les lie est même
prêt mais les poils ah ça c'est pour
ceux qui mangent le kaki pomme
imagine qu'on parle de vrais kaki dans
le tchat
pas de mêlée pas la banane c'est par un
fruit c'est une herbe folle hans fehr
verbe je crois mais choisira
valeur tu as je le voie verte quoi faire
de ces jeunes que la manne
sinon je vais plus comme un brin
hisser une pérou
et la fille c'est une fleur bananier
qu'une herbe
l'albanie s'énerver
et la fixer la barbe ou quoi non c'est
pas ça
ne tète d'arbres
plein air devant une pelouse quoi tu vas
enfin le bananier camille les plus
imposants que un brin d'herbe
c'est comme une mûre oui myrtille
et graphique une fleur yoyo la fiq
fleurs
bayer plus grand herbier jean phi long
terme du monde
donc
pas mieux c'est superbe
et un poids assez pour être précis ils
sont précis 1 et du coup alors
c'est quoi donc vers une arme et un
arbre
je pensais les banques bah ouais
chancellerie filiation des feuilles mais
bush par
yannick contrairement aux apparences
n'est pas un arbre mais une plante
herbacée en effet ne possède pas de
vrais tron mais un ce type comme les
palmiers oui tu vas pas avoir de troncs
dire que le truc est mou un peu de vide
à l'intérieur ça que j'ai vu des trucs
quand on voit des jeux taper dessus ça
sonnait creux quoi
donc
on a plein en acheter plein de banal je
remarche et il nous en reste encore
qu'on mange des bananes sur l'énergie
platini aquatique c'est à ce type de
buzz
ok s'ajouteront
en tout cas c'est bon les bananes j'aime
bien les petites bananes aussi tombé
c'est le meilleur un jour j'étais petite
banane goût framboise
bonne figue très très loin
la papaye c'est bon
jancovici d'quoi achètent plus s'il faut
pas prendre des trucs rond et on
remarque les bananes d'ananas canin
non mais tu peux acheter non celle qu'on
a acheté non mais tu peux akale tu peux
t'en fais pas poussé beaucoup à mon avis
mais tu pourrais
des bananes groupe qu'on voit c'est quoi
ce délire basse et des petites bananes
de cet écrivain pour moi c'est des
petites notes de framboise banane est
quoi
manu c'est là aussi désespérée que
mam était dévoué et 30 nuls avec les
blancs tour si pour ce bonhomme
toute façon il sait qu'il annule
non
ils poussent le bouchon allez ça va
jouer un petit peu
la question d'honneur aussi quoi
donc vous attendra à cuatro
watch 6
pour cavaliers 6,3 g 7
h il survit pas qu'il plante songé 5 mai
vont à quatre on a envie d'avancer
on va répéter un le pion semble être en
prise n'est pas vraiment à cause de
cavale et f6 fourchette
broker prend
au revoir m on n'est pas arrivé de face
magnifique
of art et eau qui se serait pris la
fourchette 10 a dit qu for you après je
vais aller au match de championnat du
monde c'est un mec te fais des 5
tu vois pas pourquoi mais tu le forfait
jeudi ce qui est super con ou
bon tu peux voir
et latour premier cas c'est pas idiot ça
mais c'est ce que tu te fais pas prendre
sur la huitième ranger votre registre
un peu le même problème que tout à
l'heure au pire
tu gagnes un dragon pour qu'ils
défendent g4 mais
ouais bon sens ne
faut pas faire confiance à sa non mais
faut pas faire confiance mais il faut
bien réfléchir pour être bien sûr va te
fait pas confiance je vérifie si tu vois
pas tu prends appui auprès de filles et
fils à merde
tu peux quand même te demander quoi
donc
6 ne va pas voir obligé trop dure la
fourchette ouais
on va voir ce qui va jouer à quatre pour
à 3
4 à trans
séparées un peu obligé non
pas qui est probante le merger mais à
quatre ça me semble tellement logique à
tâtons pions passé tu l'as vence
ne faut pas négliger le fait que l'on
posé du tour saint-ours et 7 et
mettre un peu mal des réseaux des trucs
plus tu as fait à 4 et/ou coiteau plus
n'a pas le temps s'y faire à quatre
arrêts forcés un patron à 3 sets à 2
bref cette
en fait attend tf6 je suis tout rêve
cette jeunesse matin mais la droite et à
vrai dire tu auras encore torah je crois
pour couvrir et un ami chez qui est bon
généralement on peut défendre au pire si
on devra encore d'un preuves s'ils sont
le faire
ouais donc tout ça pour dire que
tu as plus ou moins envie de balancer à
4 à 3 et est envoyé ouais
bien sûr
je vois d'autres coupes tour des quatre
c'est jouable
même si ça me semble pas super logique
erakat s'est vraiment le coup logique un
peu inquiète tu veux faire
mal apposition demande
de pousser le pion
à vrai dire
battre
tu le début alors
envoyée
mais bon peut-être pu faire d'autres
choses
peut-être temps des 8,5 où
il sert du café
paraissent ces histoires de thermos là
pour pas avoir à se déplacer
ces pratiques bonne température
il va tenter le truc avec tourbe et
c'est tombé six tours à 6 montfaucon
nepos ont apprécié quand même
j'aurais tellement eu peur avec les
blancs bah si tu votes tu as au pire ça
après il a réfléchi assez longtemps mais
je sois
non mais par contre c'est vraiment
rae mais pau c'est vrai qu'il a un peu
dans la situation dont parlait va d'hier
il peut l'y peut devoir mettre
du temps pour
pour calculer des baux selon sur les
chiens
y at il des contrôles antidopage aux
échecs ah oui mais car ça n'en a mis
quelques jours c'est normal
partie des règles après aux échecs au
delà du dopage on essaye surtout
d'éviter l'aide des technologies pendant
les parties ce qui serait une bien plus
grande admet dans le site vérifier tout
mais oui oui il ya des ya des contrôles
et c'est tout à fait normal
puisque aucun logiciel convient de
l'ordinateur dit alors on utilise un
chef base généralement qui tourne là sur
une turbine à metz y
est
et comme logiciel
moi je dis stop fichage 13 encore j'aime
bien les éval quand je passe pas trop
longtemps il ya stockfisch 14 fiches à
lagnieu tout ça ce sont des logiciels
qui sont libres libres d'accès qui sont
gratuits 26 base est pas gratuit mais
les moteurs des analyses sont gratuits
et voilà au bout de goûts de chacun
d'utiliser le moteur qui lui plaît ouais
ça chante tu peux aussi variés les
moteurs selon la position au nom de la
partie
ah bon c'est gratuit cette affiche c'est
gratuit way face aux bulls ont besoin
après chuck bass dans un moment il était
sur steam à 15 ou 20 euros le 13 mai il
n'y ait plus en ce moment
on se base en général c'est un peu plus
100 euros contre 3,4 jose logique
logique néo pop
métairie consulter sa ou pendant le
match si tu veux tu chies tu vas tu
pourras voir quelqu'un quitte envoie des
sms ou qu'ils communiquent dans la salle
avec un langage secret que vous avez une
voix non c'est pour ça que vous voyez
ils sont éteints caméras publiques ils
sont d'une grille
voilà sont des arts du verre là bas
c'est insonorisé à fond et j'imagine que
la vitre teintée ouais donc en fait le
ils sont dans leur bulle quoi donc sa
grille ça ça coûte ça est normalement
il ya un brouilleur bien moyen donc là
bon c'est vraiment bien en fait le truc
c'est que un match comme ça non ce que
je vois pas trop con ça peut tricher à
moins qu'ils soient des implants dans la
tête fin prêt on peut toujours pas nommé
par contre dans les autres peines les
tournois plus basique est jamais trop
sur la shdm en plus être contrôlés tout
le monde est justement là où pire des
cas
sinon il ya déjà eu des cas un peu par
le passé quand c'était moins surveillés
que c'était le début tu vois qu'on s'y
attendait pas du tout elles ont été pris
un peu surprise
disons-le à ce truc là j'ai aucun
d'autre part plus de doute quand les
gens sont seuls chez eux jeux sur
internet ou des choses comme ça on là tu
sais pas ce qui se passe mais ce match
là
c'est clean là tu peux pas faire mieux
en terme de sécurité en gros les les
deux tournois les plus sécurisés bon
c'est le match là c'est vraiment
car l on est proche du son pour son nez
99.99 9 9% que c'est sécurisé qui a pas
de problème et les candidats aussi je me
rappelle à berlin c'est une anecdote
comme l'a dit plusieurs fois d'ailleurs
ce qu'il était sur place avec reach look
mais ils pouvaient même pas à payer avec
la carte de crédit
au minibar qui était même pas dans la
salle de jeu mais qui est un petit peu à
l'extérieur peut-être 50 ou 100 mètres
de la salle deleu déjà du coup est déjà
là la carte bleue passé pape s'était
fait un système de brouilleurs qui
prenait en votre le justifier
et en gros pour les candidats aussi les
mesures de sécurité prises pour éviter
les communications sont assez
importantes
parce que finalement ces sites au palace
à tricher contre cramique bat toujours
pas là mais en fait on sait que moi j'ai
dit façon une présomption d'innocence
c'est quand même la base 1 donc non il
n'a pas triché pas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il est chef scam la
présomption d'innocence et j'ai pas
présomption dans le sens où il l'a fait
il ya maintenant onze ans il y avait
rien qui le prouvent ya pas eu de procès
ya aucune preuve
du coup pas là ni vous je vois pas ce
qu'on va pas avancer maintenant qu'avant
vingt seize ans plus tard
donc
mais derrière ces accusations
réciproques oui
tu va tenter quand il veut tenter dé 6 à
soit un coût de cavalli sur un coup de
dés 6 et 17 genre un truc comme ça
surprend et qui réussissent et qu'elle
va les prendre il ya tout reprend
la tour de trump
c'est pour montrer la main mais en fait
sur 17 il ya juste retour des
8es on veut prendre une cavale et
donc non excusez moi j'ai pas lu la
bonne partie des six du matin et la tête
tu dois faire qui finissent quand même
un cavalier 800 points cédant
cavaliers c'est cette non mais
n'importe quoi autour et tu reviens vers
des quizz tu fais ce truc dont on a
parlé qui est hyper fort en fait je te
dis que tu t'attaques g4 au passage
rai1 tête je dois faire car il est vite
maintenant on va pas faire va faire des
g4 g5 et je me demande s'il écoute si si
j'ai contre arrangeant rencontre pour le
moment je pense pas du tout que les
noirs soient mieux mais juge me demande
si magnus on se rappelle un jeu je
répète ce que j'ai déjà dit mais la
seule partie qui avait perdu contre
cariat qu'il en fait c'est juste ce qui
s'était entêté dans un truc où il
n'avait pas besoin de le faire et les
prophéties tôt dans le match mais n'est
pas fait si tôt dans le match 1 de côté
quand tu le fais tôt dans le match a
peut-être temps de revenir
ouais c'est comme au foot pour un but
dans les cinq premiers c'est mieux que
92e quoi
tient pas son camp tu pousses tu peut la
perdre aux blancs mais après je me
trompe peut-être tout à l'heure j'ai
bien perdu au noir contre leur dit mais
bon c'est contre leur dit alors dit la
firme allemande
et c7 direct chez pas je peux faire de
toi cet ac plus alain
dans tous les cas parce que mon tapis
des six la tour prends des six donc d'un
côté tu forcer un peu tour à 7 tu
laisses pas tour à 4 mais d'un autre
côté tu as plus des six boxes
terrible
après des relations compliquées en fait
c'est très simple en termes de pièces
tu peux tenter la prohibition des le
quercy g5 et tatati différentes options
del piero qui vient pour être assez
précis
car elle était ici se braque de cahiers
des six étapes l'uqar à lévis
après pour le cou à toutes vos idées là
pour l'instant l on perde trop marché
est peut-être que dans un coup d'oeil à
une petite différence dans la position
ça reviendra
des idées qui peuvent marcher
non mais plus on regarde va rendre plus
la région si je sais pas on va dire
c'est plus difficile à jouer pour les
bleus enfin les noirs c'est tellement
simple c à 3 c à deux troupes et trois
tours b 1 c'est un retour des quatre cd
plans ultra simple en fait ça tu peux
jouer envie de s'en lasser
basquiat 2
ouais c'est ça c'est qu'avec les noirs
l'écologique sont
bien pas besoin de trop se casser la
tête et mes post la casse pas
c'est quoi la pendule 14 affiche autant
que
j'ai mis une pub il ya peu de temps ou
pas non non longtemps je croyais ça fait
une demi heure je renvoie une petite pub
les gars la peau basse
la poupe à ce pouvoir soit et sa part
ça fait du bien ça me fait du bien là où
pas toujours je me sens beaucoup mieux
sans requinquer je m'étire après tout
voilà
pu
viser là
ça finit tôt ouais même le temps avant
le title tous d'être sur une petite
fille gatel à remarcher de noël et aux
figues attali paraguay
magnifique
je pense que tout le monde espérant que
ça joue pas trop longtemps pour avoir
bâti bien manger sa petite-fille attal
quoi bah oui
oui un randonneur vous gagnez suivants
font très bien sûr non mais tu as autant
d'arguments acquéreurs qui est club l'on
vous dira mieux qu leenhardt est pas
mieux que les blancs mais ça peut rien
devient réciproque si on est des feux de
camp
et disons là c'est
un dépôt il va pas jouer l'idiot six
fois ni du froid nul et 172 champions
bath et donc on se sent il fait des
trucs marmots quoi
nous entend pendant la pub ah bah oui on
s'aime on est au courant
on n'a pas coupé les micros
non rien couper la faim normand quant à
la pub c'est que c'est un bug switch en
fait si ton temps et la pub et le un oui
au oui/non c'est pour ceux qui n'ont pas
la pub
c'est qu'il ya un problème
c'est qu'il ya un gros problème
petit je reçois un marché après le match
as on voit qu'il ya des connaisseurs
notre chocolat pourquoi pas
ça connaît on peut être franc les deux
quoi
la vallée
f60 on va mettre la cam sur une époque
on y revient
bon cela dit sur le site il veut
peut-être g5 un départ n'est pas encore
entré sur
sûrement d'ailleurs
mais bon un petit aller-retour
et chose repartir je remets la particule
début j'ai fait par inadvertance mais je
me dis pourquoi pas pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est la petrov un très théorique magnus
qui a une petite idée mais qui semble
pas très très dangereuse honnêtement
mais je pense pas que qui veuille qui va
unis si rapide mon fab
à vrai dire je sais pas si j'espère une
une rapide ou pas
ouais je serais quand même un peu
rapidement roubaud
balech oui enfin si c'est pour ce fils
port nul
voilà parti va jouer trois et sept on
voit les combats on et synchro voilà le
courage et celle qui vient d'arriver et
il envoie g5 et non ça joue mon fab
bon je peux vous donner le ton à trois
ans
à 3 c'était notre coin
à 3 c'était notre cour
je
robinette
je peux faire tache d'huile et si si si
bons à trois très bien
trois des six
balles a encore dit mme bien qui va lui
aussi
à trouver 6,6 regagne dur contrôle des 8
tu tapes ici est à du roi et fuite et 17
bombe à la tour de vis tu
vois surtout
83,17
bon on a tué dans cette mieux bon ça
c'est par ici les blancs font les idiots
ouais non des six qui est aussi ce après
il peut tenter de 30h 4 au 6
6 pas bête h 5 km h cinq avaient perdu
commente alors j'aimerais h5 m'étais
pris quoi
je m'étais pris un tour bessette je
crois
brad est en âge 6 mai moi j'avais perdu
comme ça 6 le seul défaut
bon c'est pas notamment un travail et
voilà tu perds un pion 3 g 8 g h du fait
qu'elle et h7 en fait jean brondi la
botte
bafia piquet fils donc des 5 et attaquer
quoi un jour il fait tour à quatre tours
à 4 tours h quatre tours h6 aussi
s'attirer de faire des six
on peut affirmer fille de brancher un
tournoi fuite qui a rallié ses sept
tours dé récupérer l'option
qu'est tour trois tours prend des six
tours prend à tour huit matches
pour 3 pas mal
ça peut être un peu dangereux
en outre d'autres coupes en mai la
raison brimeux
ouais tu peux te planter
la tour qui arrive en c6 bon ça va être
complètement nul encore mais tu peux te
planter il en rit à trois noms ouais les
niveaux il se prend pas la tête
aujourd'hui c'est très bien en fait
il se met pas en pls à trop réfléchir
style de la maison effectivement c'est
bien de pas se mettre trop à l'otan
alors voilà il reste est du reste rien à
voir avec la pendue le
fraudeur doucement ouais c'est à peu
près ça pour dix coups bas
mais pour jouer le tt ouais
donc la raison magnus ans
il a raison de jouer
vraiment une cadence très très adapté tu
sais qui viennent
c'est saïss moule
attendu pour les parties d'époque
hongrie tchouk tchouk samatan
psc1 réfutable parce que mike est quand
même très bon et tu es là tu réfléchis
comme un fou et il peut encore faire
c'est déstabilisant de jouer contre des
joueurs comme ça
ouais c'est terrible
c'est terrible
donc à temps je vais créer un petit
message avec nous on fait pas de pause
comme les autres mais du coulage un
petit truc à faire il fait donc si je
regardais
bah écoute on a peu prévu ce qui
pourrait se passer on sait pas
s'ils vont suivre
les lignes
suspense yonnais
mais
pour l'instant dépôt tient très bien de
choc pas d'erreur on en aura un deuxième
coup
l'ordi bien sûr d'onagawa
les blancs peuvent essayer de tenter ici
ou là des choses donc avec la poussée
des pions h avec l'absolution des
peut-être un jour mais le pion à trois
on voit déjà bien avancé mais
quand même
de bons espoirs contre jaune offre donc
clairement sinon le temps ils font à
deux tours b 3 tours bien et basta quoi
est-ce qu'il est serein magnus
mois plus tôt
et la reprise cernon est moins serein il
est pas très william
jeanty
très bon
la tradition
moi j'aurais perdu puntos à l e punto ch
ah bah il se présente en constant
poussé par l'offshore
alors est-ce que les tours aux
nombreuses quoi ouais tu oses
va comprendre william saurin oui mais
bon c'est le rêve de vieux non c'est
plus la télé donc c'est passé encore les
pubs fait longtemps j'ai pourtant du
même sort d'ailleurs maintenant t'es sur
qui a valu huit temps aussi tout reprend
là pour faire drôle d'ailleurs pas
je m'en veux faire en fait non mais
j'essaye de regarder
résister
ok boomers
cinq ans regarde pas trop la tête
non pas du tout du coup
jamais me rase pas
arrêté par
théophile
ses pattes et le fils moi je regarde des
films après 1 mais oui
ce que je veux voir à la télé gelée sur
l'ordi donc bon ouais tu voir des échecs
comme time la télé tu zappes trouve pas
et chaque fois je vais à vos
télécommandes changer quand on n'en a
pas du coup tu assures twitch
tu peux zapper longtemps et pourquoi des
échecs mais magnus il a l'air désespéré
et j'ai l'impression que l'epo il calque
fin évidemment il calcule pas en criant
salle de repos j'en fais des gens disent
ou je pense qu'il est
présent en confiance il en can
cette rocade
ah non il est bien il est bien n'est pas
celle que son équipe auteur avait fait
un truc c'est sur internet
avant tout je regardais comment les
échecs aux remises se déplacer
sur youtube ouais sur youtube et puis
aventure garder sur les magazines
son minitel
non mais après tu avais pas forcément
les parties commenté comme là mais tu
pouvais suivre en direct
comme si là tu vas sur check points
comme cela chez wendt
white avait des coups à des parties en
direct voilà je ne sont pas comptés quoi
et avait un peu le petit module qui
était mauvais mais qui n'est pas son
truc
et c'est peu quand même suivre
est-ce qu'il ya encore la droite qui
réduit tout maintenant on voit ensuite
devient une option
juste rené angélil gentiment
en russie à la belle époque les parties
était commenté à la radio et
à la belle époque
sur le transistor
il y avait deux diagonales tv oui mais
c'était sur internet aussi diagonale
terry base c'était pas sur la télé à
proprement dit rien les balbutiements
des
déchets non internet avant youtube
non mais à la télé peut-être été un peu
passé le
les immo par les trucs comme ça je sais
quand j'étais petit
mes parents directs c'était un vrai y
avait un peu de
dérision
kasparov et karpov sur tf1 où il y avait
les résumés d'après-match ouais
c'est pas du direct 8 heures par jour
tout cas c'est pas une ouverture réussie
1 pour magnus
le cavalier h 4 c'était une petite idée
mais elle n'a pas pas casser trois
pattes à un canard
encore non mes valeurs même si magnus la
gagne ce sera pas l'idée dans
l'ouverture
l'annoncé pour savoir mais c'était pas
c'était pas du directoire
au sport
sur les digital
dont il a joui il faut encore enfin car
lé 8 cavalli apsys
reprendre faire notre coup franc h4 à
nous faire un
alors h4 moi j'avais perdu comment
j'avais fait à 2
qui avait huit roi ici je m'étais pris
tour de tours à trois mois c'est une
autre ligne où j'avais réussi à perdre
qui a valu à 6,3 g 7 et des six j'ai
joué ça contre leur dis
qu'est ce qui est
si mal
alors design vraiment un gros avantage
blanc là moi je lai des prix ça
c'est pour montrer contre l'ordi en
réalité sur le web mais toute manière je
pense qu'avec les blancs surtout aussi
fait pas nue contre leur dit si tu
essaies de jouer le gachon ses rôles
d'ailleurs je compte l'ordi sur le web
allemand
et du coup il fait que cinq ans h4 et à
deux tours c'est pour ça qu'ils
commencent oui bon il fait le tour à
quatre
tours à quatre ses formes et les autres
idées qu'on avait du coup tu veut taper
là
et tu bloques toujours avec tour des
quatre tours à quatre c'est propre c'est
très clean comme coup
elles sont battus fait tout reprend et h
si tu commences à être beaucoup mieux
à menton tout est payant et que les
blancs
et même si tu faisais un truc comme ça
juste pour montrer je ne sais pas du
tout si ça va mais
on fait que même sa
tête avec les blancs on va pas la gagner
ça la floride ont même champion bétail
heures
donc c'est vraiment dur à gagner mais il
y avait un truc j'ai vu le
les vals qui s'emballe est la cause de
tout à fait leurs preuves
sur price à trois points 7 heures retour
au cdr je réfléchissais pas et on prend
aussi soin qui évite
un piège
ok du coup ça peut être un piège
c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment dur
sans ordi de voir comment jouer le cas
et c'est pour ça que magnus trépied je
suis autant avec une épaule et serein
parce que voir hk tour à quatre des six
avec idée surtout pour h4 tour e menaces
après à 2.973 paris vii tour 7 maths
c'est vraiment dur
mais bon on te fait des sacrifices c'est
vraiment pour je veux le battre
lors des idées de m
2 plus safe ch 4 h 5 la première
intuition
quant au retour la merde non
à 5 ans
cette crème
mais tu voyages ça tout est
bon
la tâche si ça me parle plus a priori
mais bon ça il faut calculer en touche
avec le pire - qui va et qu'on a regardé
tout à l'heure et qui avait huit machin
s'attache 5 c'est le plus à le danger
disposition avec les noirs c'est qu'en
fait ça paraît rien enfin un petit fayt
faut faire plus attention que ce qu'il
n'y paraît visuellement mais bon on est
poèmes si je vis tu joues pas tu aimes
beau tempo et déjà pris 50 minutes sans
que ça va n'est pas en mode
wi puis calcul sur le temps de magnus
dans sa salle de repos et des biens est
sur son petit écran en 2d
et tour trois
balles option à il me fait tellement
peur
on va défendre mais bon j ph 7
du coup n'est jamais mieux actuellement
surtout qu'avec les pions angers 5 b5 et
des cinq prochaines années
la prépa de magnus aura pas été une
réussite aujourd'hui clairement
écoute on verra qui va être détruit dans
cette position
non mais pourquoi pas face au jury joue
une partie
pas la fin du monde
annoncée pas la fin du monde
hellmund fine del mundo
el mundo à mundo l'étape solide devant
et fait penser à hulk un peu
raide
je pense qu'il a inspiré un clairement
un peu déçus de leur prépare d'ailleurs
général à moi je trouve au contraire les
joueurs sont très bien préparés
nul c'est le résultat le plus logique
est-ce que c'est dangereux pour manu ce
nom là un magnus peut arrêter les frais
à tout moment en fait c'est magnus qui
décide si ça continue ça continue pas si
ça continue ça va devenir dangereux ça
peut devenir dangereux pour les deux à
un moment donné mais magnus lui il a le
pouvoir d'arrêter la partie
immédiatement c'est la seule différence
en fait ma news peuvent faire nul après
si magnus veut jouer le lien en fête
sera chance réciproque ce sera fin 50 50
ce sera 90 % nul 5% gains de chaque côté
mais il sera pas devant je pense
non après il peut
bien question de zab le fait que les
mecs aujourd'hui près par deux fois avec
les turbines vu que le jeu préparé loin
d'un jeu humain ont-ils tendance à faire
davantage d'erreurs et oui
on va le truc c'est qu'il faut qu'ils
connaissent ce que la turbine a dit et
fait qu'il fasse l'effort de mémoire
mais en plus ce qui qui comprennent la
saveur
et au savon en devenir et
et comme enjeu la position en fait il
s'agit pas de savoir c'est censé aller
d'après la turbine avoir la position en
reste trop compliqué pour le gérer
humainement donc faut arriver à lille et
de quoi c'est souvent une erreur
peut-être que certains peut faire de
juste évoqué leur dit que ça allait je
veux la partie jeu voir mais c'est pas
une préparation film ça parce que
finalement si tu te retrouves la laure
diabo te dire ce qu'il veut et que toi
dans l'échiquier était incapable de
jouer les bons coups bas alors autant je
veux un truc un peu moins bon mais être
capable de faire
mais ça peut amener parfois des partis
qui sont un peu moins bien joué en
milieu de jeu puisque les plans sont
tellement difficiles et joue sur
tellement de petites nuances que ça
devient impossible même de reproduire ce
que tu as appris c'est là que que ces
joueurs là sont très fort c'est quand
ils sont capables de jouer un éventail
de position impressionnant ouais c'est
ça et normalement donc oui leur prêt
passe de battre faire d'effort de
mémoire et de deux
connaître les plans après ça ok juste
option là celle là celle là son espace
jeux de telle ou telle manière c'est un
petit peu comme les réglages en formule
1 quelque part c'est que tu vas voir tu
vas dire oui je vais avoir une voiture
qui va vraiment très très vite donc une
prépa havre et man à la limite limite
mais bon je vais avoir tellement de mal
dans les virages que sur 70 tours je
vais finir par sortir de la piste où tu
préfères être un peu plus hype comme on
peut faire un peu ça aura des positions
alors dit donne plus 0,3 mais quand tu
vois la position tu dis c'est pas pour
moi merci mais pas pouvoir merci
je te la lester jeu vague sur les
besoins nets fiction par les deux
formules en ce moment un petit trait
formule
pour ça qu'on parle d'échec
un petit coup d'aileron pour gagner en
appui aérodynamique c'est exactement ça
ray
selon vous combien de temps de réflexion
dont on laisse alors dit pour chaque
coup pourquoi il soin pour qu'ils sont
un petit la bataille la lettre par les
humains bas ça dépend quel ordinateur tu
utilises ci vise le cloud d'amazon avec
chez pas combien de puissance toi tu as
15 secondes ouais même chance une
semaine par coûter bien
mais en général tu es deux minutes
plus tôt qu'on tombe téléphone tempo
déjà bonne chance
téléphone tempo tu as une chance encore
non lui mais sa défense du cdpa de oui
c'est choquant et déjà pas super bien
quoi t'es pas heureux à nous on n'est
pas super bien je pense que la plupart
des gens s'ils satire morts déjà et
c'est juste un téléphone quoi chasser un
ordi
après pour les analyses il arrive qu'ils
fassent tourner les ordinateurs sur une
position jusqu'à 7 8 10 12 à 1 on veut
vraiment aller pour avoir le fin fond
des trucs
n'ont pas formulé à frank williams qui
est mort il ya quelques jours c'est lui
le patron de williams renault tout ça à
l'époque
qui lui même contre un boulier en bois
ou une planche dessus
corbeau un accord vois ça peut être très
fort
sata impressionné quand même le coup de
dés gravier qui doit-on faire monter le
niveau de l'eau pour récupérer de la
bouffe les corbeaux
très intelligent
très intelligent les corbeaux
dirai pas qui travaille avec mes pots
dans l'équipe
s'étale sur le clavier quoi
ils peuvent remonter de la bouffe
attaché un fil aussi
un petit déroule au final
ça doit cliquer un corbeau parce que lui
bien que son pack
est ce qu'on est sûr à 100 % et
l'espagne prépa peu importe la
profondeur qui avec les blancs dans 100%
des cas ouais on en est sûr on est sûr
que ça n'existe pas
d'un coût de 6 ans tournait pas au
courant pour l'instant ça se trouve
c'est théoriquement possible
qu'on pense c'est que non
j'espère aussi que non
dans le jeu serait
dans la fuite est quoi c'est un gem
corbeau qui a démocratisé la bird
je crois qu'ils ont réussi à apprendre à
jouer aux échecs à des singes alors je
crois je sais pas je suis pas sûr mais
je veux gagner quelque chose d'un clic
dans se sont embrassés à t'expliquer
je crois que j'ai eu des choses ils ont
trouvés ils ont essayé ça c'est sûr
travaux que le sage devant un mondial
des fonds se déposant sur sa petrov
pas s'ils ont mis toutes les règles ou
quoi mais ils ont essayé d'apprendre
ça piqué
joue l'orang outan ouais je ne voulais
pas dire de bêtises mais je crois que
c'est les orangs outans mais bon
c'est magnifique en fait quand ils
pensent vrai que je relise mais je crois
qu'ils ont réussi vous sais pas si c'est
les règles complètes ou quoi mais c'est
vrai qu'on y pense c'est extraordinaire
c'est gênant
pour apprendre à me choque
tels sont beaucoup plus intelligents je
ne jouerai pas à se trouver
j'ai tout analysé alors dit je n'ai
vraiment aucun intérêt ça fait nul le 4
5 il n'y a rien à connaître voir partir
et jeté des cailloux
pour une parcours on dort une fois qu'il
aura joué on peut voir sur de chasse
comme comme ça je sais pas
pour magnus ce temps de réflexion non
non le truc c'est qu'en fait si là
encore comme on l'expliqué depuis tout à
l'heure il a encore là nul en poche et
qui a réuni 8 qui avait des f 6 est
comme ça peut être un peu dangereux
bailly calcule bien puisque là il peut
encore arrêté la partie ce qui sera
peut-être plus le cas dans deux trois
coups
oui donc salon il peut prendre sa
décision après pour l'instant il peut
encore essayer de pousser un peu son
adversaire à la faute
c'est l'heure de la pub à bah oui quand
même
c'est bien l'australien
sa clique un peu là ça
puis ben
non pas la pub rabat une petite pub ça
fait plaisir
bon mon fab
c'est pas pas la journée de rêve quand
même pour le moment on espère que ça
s'emballe un petit peu pour que ça fasse
nul ça fasse du loup et
on revient plaisir
plaisir aide
pas on a toujours notre option marché de
noël quand même fig à terre mais bon tu
as plus la nuit arrive tard plus ça va
être compliqué sur le papier le résumé
albert qui égala que du coup on est très
bonne
pour nous en fait fort aixois qui elle
annule dans l'heure qui vient soit sinon
vous pouvez jouer ton voyage ah non
jusqu'à eu 18 heures
dans le futur on ne peut pas craindre
que le tableau ne puisse pas faire
autrement que faire du rab il suffit de
raccourcir les cadences le temps de
réflexion il y aura plus deux nuls donc
non il ya une solution connue pour
éviter ce problème juste à l'est pas en
place n'est pas appliquée mais mais la
solution existe à ce problème
et elle est simple
séchoir oups mais on attend plus il
associe ce
fait on peut prendre une saucisse pour 2
après toujours aux noms mais bien
partout contre lui feront
voudrait bien chausse avec un chocolat
pimenter un peu le chocolat piment à
l'extérieur on arrive le show c'est très
bien
nouveauté théorique
cfrp 8 il me fait chier avec ça aurait
pu faire annuler une heure et demie dans
ces cas
c'est magnifique ce serait magnifique
d'après moi ce qui me fait plaisir c'est
que pour ça enfin plus annuler puis à
des partie insipide les gens s'ennuient
mois ils veulent voir des échecs plus ça
va dans mon sens de dire que ben il faut
faire des réformes ça fait maintenant 17
ans que je le dis ça fait 17 ans que
j'ai raison mais
elles ont 20 ans mais ça ça a
complètement dans mon sens fait ce truc
intéressant toute ta vie mais que non
d'être en tournée
très bon marketing pour ça que les gens
regardent et
donc moi quelque part ça m'arrange
atteinte aux acteurs entraient en
question
trois
dirigeants bien l'appeler le i de lits
dans son petit but salir mais aussi quoi
le hisser le
scb bouffe ou quoi baky qui sera en neuf
pubs qu'ils vont envoyer une photo blanc
peut
commencer pub ça fait suer tout le monde
et je n'arrive pas à en comprendre le
sens profond mais je suis très heureux
mais non je ne sais pas et puis il faut
mettre autant j'arrive ça me dépasse je
veux trop non plus
en fait un an que la pub avait déjà sur
l'écran bas on va à droite à thiès comme
en gros tu dis oui j'ai fait déjà public
enfin détrompe toi tu bloques au fil des
joueurs qui sont les palos et
publicitaires
alors à tanger mais les chaises tadmur
tu as tout âge et en profiter pour
mettre un petit inverse elle file chèque
pour les les couronnes donnés j'aurais
tout seul et je mette un lien vers mon
livre dans le sens si les gens veulent
avoir mon livre dédicacé et à jusqu'à
cette clique jusqu'à ce soir pour le
commander donc je vais mettre un lien
direct dans le chat pour les dédicaces
pour les dédicaces jusqu'à ce soir si
vous l'achetez schéma qui dépose
échiquier aussi y aller poser chicken on
en parlera ce soir des échiquiers
puisque faut que je passe une négoce
avec baky pour qu' il est ils prennent
le 20 tonnes pour qu'ils viennent faire
signer les échiquiers je pense qu'il va
pas vouloir ce que c'est compliqué mais
on va essayer d'en gratter de 3
way donc le ctge le lien alpha échec
pour racheter le petit jour où tu chopes
je sois pas tendre le shop
enlevé
avec le bordereau
présent on pourra parler d'échec est
très bien
un petit peu tous les
aspects de cette montre les watts de
bowden notamment
et didactique à des couleurs
assez bien je vais être entre entre 600
et 1200 mais c'est très bien qu'ils des
couleurs s'est fait moins austère que
près d exercice et un peu tous un bon
livre généralistes pour commencer si tu
commences que témoin de 1200 sur czech
comme entrevoit entre débutants et
jusqu'à 1200 il ya un peu de tout et un
peu de finale et un peu il ya un peu de
tout dessus
très beau livre a forcément un
bordereau validé par fab
ouais ils m'ont dit on dit très bien
de partout mais
cherchait un professionnel mais dans un
carton les professionnels aux
professionnels dont
on pense faire une b2 ouais on pense
faire une version 2
donc voilà petite dédicace si vous
voulez que je fasse une dédicace aussi
tu l'a fait devant ouais bon preuve
enfin on peut faire ça vous fait plaisir
mais de basse oui mais sait-on lionel
messi de monde cette rue bois pour faire
plaisir
combien de voix
à dakar d'ailleurs s'ils voulaient que
je fasse alors faudra dire le nombre de
à
le citer dead
oui ils n'étaient pas les deux grands
domaines on pouvait mettre le lien de
côté ça remarche est en marche mais un
jour ou l'autre
pourquoi ne pas faire jusqu'à moins de
1800 ça touchait plus de monde bah c'est
pas facile de faire un livre de zéro à
1800 et on essaie de faire un truc bien
pour te faire quelque chose de bien pour
les gens qui commencent et jusqu'à 1200
maintenant le prochain on essaiera de
faire quelque chose entre 1300 et 1400
et 2000 mais c'est plus facile de faire
1400 2000 que 1 recevra un peu près
l'avenir est en vrai oui il a par le
calcul
jusqu'à 2500
pieds 17 et un coup ça perd un pion que
lecavalier f6 est assez utiles pour
protéger le pion elle voudrait nous
faire que les pro b 6 mai date en
prendrait cinq échecs
donc bon j'ai envie d'un pion et ça se
trouve on avait mieux faire que ça
du genre qui décède en outre l'échangé
et comptines avec le a de quoi
plonger
non mais vraiment feria face à en fait
ça fait un salaire tout con mais c'est
énorme 22 coup pas très menaçant allez
les blancs on a vu plein de fois où ils
font des choses aussi c'est pas si ça me
paraît énorme
la fia quoi magnus vous croyez beh cadre
des tombées 7 je pense que quelqu'un on
l'a dit comme il a encore là nul en
poche il calcula font maintenant ce qui
sait qu'il est encore à la porte de
sortie et il veut être sûr de pas
prendre de risque s'il pense qu'il ya un
risque qu'il va prendre la porte de
sortie
ouais où il va pousser jusqu'au moment
où il a encore la porte de sortie parce
que je cahute kayak city va pas
disparaître comme ça non plus
compliqué en fait que le site crache pas
magique quand tu as un site que tu
envoies des liens et pas mille personnes
qui se connectent en même temps en fait
il ya c'est dur mais c'est vrai que
j'ai encore magnus
il veut afficher en tant qu'île je viens
vite on est déjà ils ont deux des 29
coups d'éclat reste
11h35 france qu il n'y a pas de panique
ah bah non
c'est la beauté des parties lentes
du serveur du pakistan suez rwe
jeff bezos sans sueur face au nombre de
connexions sur alpha échec mais aussi
vraiment racheter sa fille prenne un
arrêté à l'aune masculine un bon plan
pour réussir à détrôner amazon
je suis dégoûté par ce qui ne veut pas
là et on le sent des bouteilles ce qui
veux pas là le vrai je suis apte à fait
d'accord avec ça il veut vraiment pas
faire nul mais comme il a encore la
porte de sortie
qui dieu les bases de son ami passe
comme ça
ici vous pouvez apprendre et progresser
grâce à nos outils d'entraînement nos
abonnés premium débute à 25 euros par an
plus d'informations sur ce point comme
membership pour progresser vous avez
aussi le fait que c'est pas si mal fait
leur truc c'est vraiment bien toutes les
ja depuis à des 125 leçon que j'ai fais
toi tu as fait un tas de vidéos et
globalement il ya beaucoup de contenu et
chaque courant
donc
tchatche.com c'est aussi une très bonne
alternative pour progresser aux échecs
sur le numérique dont je pense que vous
connaissez déjà mais y aie aie il ya
tous les outils pour progresser et si
vous travaillez entre une demi-heure et
une heure par jour l'abonnement aux
ordres et montrez vous suffira pas ce
que c'est avec l'abonnement on est
limité dans le temps d'utilisation de du
site vous avez des exercices tactiques
les puzzles rush vous avez tout un tas
de choses à faire les vidéos les leçons
et il y en a vraiment beaucoup de leçons
bonne leçon de kôji cannes sans rigoler
sur les joueurs et c'est donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
ouais non pour
25 euros par an
mieux qu'un livre vaut très cher mais
bon faut avoir envie de travailler sur
l'ordinateur c'est la différence mais
c'est les deux choses se complètent bien
oui plein au sein l'un n'empêche pas
l'autre
les derniers ajouts aux explications des
coûts et bilan est je sais pas j'ai pas
encore
testé les inside là qui sortent je crois
qu'ils ont fait sur les bouteilles mais
dit oui est-ce qu'on peut te prendre
pour la bêta bruits détrompe toi
ils ont fait un nouveau truc pareil tu
regardes j'ai pas encore regardé mais
ils ont une nouvelle fois il te dise un
peu ce que tu fais combien tu te prendre
fourchette
basse m'intéresse
under travail qui fourche à tous sous
ton jeu robert
patrick roger tirage suite ça te
pressure kadhafi sur ces cars et 10 et
20 km à 6,3 à 17 c sur non
je sais pas un coucou un clic
h 4g tu as fait peut-être ça pour éviter
h 5 h quatre étapes u15 parce qu'il a
prises en passant
on sait pas si rare en fait briller la
position de terre ait jamais atteint et
cette option
aurait peut être est il répète et il se
bat
je pense le toilettes il voir une gorgée
mongin du raisin je sais pas au fond de
se voir
ces magnifiques alley
ça j'ai rarement vu qu alors peut-être
alfos accrue sur la face du fauteuil
mais oui le phosagro qui est là et
magnus qui revient
à l'époque et attend et c'est bizarre si
ci fais ça pour faire annuler en se
levant par la bride et cherche à voir
s'il va pas impuni va pas répéter
il s'est rapproché du 40e ouais
ça arrive on va le message que cherche
la petite bouteille d'eau je vais bien d
altérer jeux lontan
merci à kevin m'a fait découvrir soviets
middle games technique ça a changé ma
vie ah oui le fameux livre de romanowski
1 j'avais dit que ce livre exceptionnel
mais voilà si vous êtes un peu plus fort
way soviets middle games technique c'est
magnifique comme livre vraiment
magnifique les échecs à l'ancienne plein
de concept stratégique
fondamentaux pour pouvoir avancer
comprend mieux comprendre le jeu est
justement après pouvoir même mieux
comprendre le jeu moderne et pourquoi
est ce que parfois entrant transgresse
les règles etc mais sa magnifique livret
ça faut avoir vécu en russie pour la
voir dans ton âge
osseux 8000e je le lis en ce moment s
était dans mes recommandations
65 euros sur amazon quand même et je
crois qu'il était rééditée par quality
chess
possible il a été réédité
tue pas si bas qu'il ad'ailleurs
caniveaux pour le bouquin rapporté en
1500 à mon avis hein tu peux
c'est quoi le plan pour les blancs autre
que nul va essayer de faire un travail à
plein-temps dati va dire rien de
convaincant jamais mais
[Musique]
ça m'a conseillé stratégie moderne de
l'uteq parkman en fait il ya plein de
kilos qui leur compte tu connais
personne de fort dans mon entourage qui
la lui
à l'époque même
c'est à dire que mon père perd avec quoi
j'ai lu des trucs dans les finales
ouverture
bon pour les finales c'est correct je
pense pas à ça ça peut aider du coup je
suis donc on parle je connais pas en
fait déjà datés sais pas s'ils vont
attendre que ce à quoi
on va bien voir 50 60 ans de livres
kindle bien mieux que la série j'ai ma
garde va s'ériger à ma garde déjà la
pensée bien pour le calcul la tactique
mais pour le jeu positionnelle il m'a
dit
oui c'est difficile d'envoyer un jeu
pauliste j'étais sûr de faire des livres
sur deux jeux positionnelle quand il
comprend rien
[Rires]
mais le soviet s'il est bien géré
j'ai lu un peu mais les regarde je crois
que sur les tactiques et le calcul c'est
pas mal
réceptionner après moi j'en sais rien
prost juste histoire de mettre un taxe
fait plaisir mais je pense est que
l'adil concert c'est à jamais été top
100 mondial déjà c'est que
tu peux pas trop comprendre on pas une
grand chose mais je crois que sur les
calculs et la tactique il a dit que
c'était bien
mais en fait ils sont calculés des telle
chose n'est pas le romanowski moi je
trouve vraiment bon mais après vous
aimez les vieux livres fruits mais les
vieux trucs pour avoir envie d'apprendre
des choses fondamentales qui sont plus
forcément vrai aujourd'hui enfin aura
envie de faire un travail rétrospectif
quoi
pour noël sur la stratégie environ midi
samba celui là le romanowski on en parle
depuis tout à l'heure sera le conseil du
jour
après ba qui vous donnera d'autres
conseils de main quand il passera et la
plainte de mon livre en bas il doit
avoir le celui qui fascine à conseiller
il est quelque part il est des monster
quelque chose là lé monde star
annonceurs plein ou un truc comme ça
ouais les monsters est ce qui la
liquidation love of the chase bourbaki
je vais regarder si alpha et chaque
marche
ça arrive que j'aime bien moi
la méthode man tu aimes
c'est bien je dirais pour d'après moi
c'est bien entre 2002 et 2004
stratégie moderne de vote sonne
d'après vos lignes
asie est-ce que tu l'as le liquidation
est-ce que tu la liquidation nathan ce
qu'on va le chercher je les aime bien
gelée ici j'aime bien pourra le faire en
live quelques
promeneurs alpha trop mal je passe
quelque chose bakir
oui il l'a attends je vais le montrer du
tout ce que j'avais
j'aime bien vous allez voir un petit je
deviens tu l'as vu ou pas
c'est benjamin
the world est en fait bon c'est fait
pour travailler des finales c'est un peu
ludique c'est des finales où il un
avantage matériel il faut savoir s'il
faut échanger pas échanger et comment
échanger s'il faut le faire je
trouve intéressant parce que tu
travailles des finales de pions en même
temps et finale deux tours et les
finales de dames et les finales de
fouler finale de cavale ça prend des
transitions ça t'apprend les transitions
et et c'est pas mal foutu et comme je
trouve que c'est une des bases du jeu et
que et que c'est quelque chose faut
vraiment travailler parce qu' une fille
née pour gagner une partie est un
avantage matériel ou tu es mieux faut
travailler la transition de la faim
bassin arrive que j'aime beaucoup entre
eux on va dire vrai 1500 1600 bah moi je
lui tu vois jusqu'à 2003 toi tu pourrais
dire jolie bailly lieu
mais pas pour y lire enfin web entre
1500 1600 et même jusqu à 26,60 dis ce
que je pense
mais en vrai c'est bien pour tout le
monde quoi c'est sympa
et intéressant alors assez récent et
mais j'aime bien le la couverture
et le cap à principes fondamentaux les
échecs et ça j'aime pas ta faim j'aime
pas trop mais c'est bien pour commencer
ou quoi impériaux je trouve mon book mon
livre mieux
c'est un bon livre mais juste pour
commencer maintenant et à mieux quoi
mais des trucs intéressants aldo d'un
beau début elles sont vachement
intéressante
décline à 2 en août a toujours su en
fait tu as toujours su et
queen zing très bons premiers chapitres
tous les chats bitton l orange habitera
des finales de damian rarement des
choses dessus et c'est pas mal j'ai
durant les finales aux âmes mais il ya
des bons trucs jeu rien damache à un
moment donné pour contrer la première
rangée enfin ont fait montre heures
après mais il ya des trucs intéressants
tu valides ça va pas mal en fin
d'exercice ou quoi ça fait chercher
c'est bien je suis un des tout premiers
exemples j'ai bien aimé
ce même le tout premier d'ailleurs
bon évidemment pour toi c'est facile
pour les gens tu vas même à 2000 da
machin parce que tu couvres les zemates
assez des bons trucs géométriques j'aime
bien ça c'est que le premier exemple un
truc plus complet beaucoup plus
compliqué mais là aussi pour bloquer
tous les échecs il faut saddam chez plus
comment
il fait un truc avec saddam pour passer
pour des chèques et avancé tim k way
non l'autre la
capella d'annoncer si
mais ces intérêts sont partout
alors eux aussi écrit presque comme tu
l'écris source et un viol un w
et baky qu'on a des photos de l'ipsc on
peut plus avoir à les secrets de la
stratégie moderne aux échecs quoi et oui
j'aimais bien les livres de murs tâchés
mais bien
john watson
je peux le montrer
par baky interposés
droit qui arrive en parachute le nommait
baumannii fille la mère fantastique sur
un gamin un neveu ou un fils ou un
quelqu'un que tu vas prendre les déchets
qui peut faire le doublé au mental et
voilà c'était bon pour les seuils de
parler d'échec quand même la position de
façon se fait depuis à peu près 14h15
14h20 qu'on l'a sur la fée 1h40 qu'on
est là dessus bon
je peux aller masterplan quelque part à
m'occuper quand tu cherches les grimaces
bon en fait il ya plein de bons livres
regarde
les kinois
autres tomes
le vert
ça c'est vieux livres
alors ça se voit à la calligraphie
dessus
ils sont pas le viol et pourtant
ah bah oui c'est très connu ça c'est
bien
c'est le marine un burn forme de legends
intéressant
sachant que là
mais qui recommande le seul
livre de la jungle
[Musique]
au scotch game bon on vous recommande
pas montre
wastiaux voir passer bah oui ce sont des
blocs cette opposition tient
je tends ma position ouais
ah ah bah oui
alors au niveau d'ouverture bon quand
même compliqué mais mais pour ceux qui
veulent lâcher des céciliennes ou quoi
intéressant et qui livre coécrit avec
cornetto
ça petit livre tranquille où les
professionnels je pense que le bail qui
pâturent l'avoir petite interview début
d'exercice une petite partie analysée de
chacun et les monsters est monster
planning de vivaces alors il ya deux
tomes 1 sur les deux est aussi le
monster ending j'imagine où je sais plus
comment il s'appelle pour les finales et
ils sont bien
sont bien faire tout seul son bien pour
aussi pour les cours ils sont bien pour
plein de raisons ils
découpent ça en plusieurs chapitres avec
des thèmes et
et je faisais partie typique qu'illustre
bien et à un moment il s'arrête dans la
position y voilà qu'est ce que vous
aurez ici je vous propose trois
possibilités suis là je suis là où je
suis là des fois il ya des petits tiens
il ya des petits et les petits pièges ou
quoi donc c'est intéressant
de 10 des deux bouquets intéressante
mais bon bien sûr le gagner aux échecs
sariska nabab ah bah oui le livre rouge
reste la base un peu l'obligatoire avoir
dans sa bibliothèque est un peu d'auto
promo
non mais ça mais on a montré pas mal de
livres intéressants la tambouille voilà
on a repêché reboiser la partie pour les
gens qui arrivent et
bon c'est pas si man is a finalement été
découvert nul
on sent un peu dépité de faire ça mais
tu vas pas mieux vaut pas mieux mais à
vrai dire il ya pas mieux
mais il peut juste essayer autre chose
parce qu'objectivement c'est nul c'est
bon alors dit c'est en pratique
de faire craquer l'adversaire
en asie le bel et bien pour les joueurs
intermédiaires alors ça je sais pas je
n'ai pas lu mais passer moins de temps
sur les ouvertures et plus de temps sur
le jeu en fait de witte
ça fait deux
ouais après je sais pas si mon coeur
je n'ai pas lu
je pense pas qu'il va te dévoiler quand
même toutes ces prépas quoi
sa part assuré vraiment plusieurs et 40
minutes
faire
ça mais ils sont pas mal moi j'aime bien
c'est
bien vu ce nom c'est un auteur je
connaissais avec droite ce qui lorsque
le fait que s'élancent à moi j'ai pas
ces versions la javel et vieux nationale
play
technique en attendant nucléaire ou je
sais pas quoi défensive enfin bon bref
c'était dit j'avais beaucoup aimé quand
j'étais petit et
l'a recommandé après ils ont ils ont
fait d une autre édition ils ont
peut-être un peu
chapitre ou quoi est il sous peu après
il a écrit des livres tout seul est ce
que le fait que cela soit à touches mais
ils sont vraiment ils sont bien là ah
bon mais voilà tous bords ont souvent le
temps pour être chaud ce
cas ci on filme vite confie après 5
c'est bon travail partie
brassard est vraiment figure et 35
minutes par ici on l'avait vraiment
après 40 minutes un moment on a fait des
conseils à lire on a fait le téléachat
tout ça c'était c'était sympa quoi bon
bah écoute et attendrait une petite
merci d'avoir suivi
moment j'espère que ça vous a plu nos
petits cons ces livres on pourra le
refaire pour les gens
savent bien jouer gros coquillage
vieille qui a oui bravo à temps non il
maintient son biais baissier
encore trois bons résultats et
il est vraiment bon moment
mais moi je peux pas visibles arrimé à
la barre il se présentait il a le pseudo
le prime et le pronom enfin ça fait
beaucoup
réfléchir un peu stoïque il pas très
ravie
ariane
paris non mais ravi le langage anglais
je sais pas
j'ai trente secondes ça va être allez va
pas être facile à reduce qui a pas grand
chose à dire on ne voit pas grand chose
mais on va essayer de faire un truc de
dix minutes quand même si on arrive à
passer dix minutes sur cette partie
javaux
s'écrit gros qu as tu vas bientôt le
savoir kml tu va le sentir passer
des joueurs qui quittent qui quitte la
salle de jeu et donc on sera de retour à
19 heures avec le prez et oui
là là là à
aller baky
chat lalala lalala
à
l'eba qui
t'a lalala lalala
à aller baky
shalalala
ah ah
à l'eba qui allons